You know what? I'm going to start with some asminold. >> The
young turds jank yogurt. Uh yogurt.
>> Chank chank called out asmin gold apparently. Okay.
And it's it's just really this whole segment's really funny to
me cuz I feel like they're talking about different things and
I don't know. The whole thing is goofy. Okay. So, let's I put
this in the title first. Anyway, let's check this out real quick.
All right. Let's check it out. Asminop
is always awesome.
Asmin Gold titles have been crazy these days. They want me dead.
And well,
he certainly is public enemy number one in a lot of ways right
now. Uh had a had an Asmin Gold related meltdown. So this is
the title of the video here. Asmin Gold says protesters should
be used for >> Oh, hold on. Hold on. My music might be
really loud over the video right now.
>> Slave labor. Uh, now this isn't completely wrong, but
it's certainly not completely right. And so anyway, let's go
back. We're going to watch the clip and we're going to see how
they approach it. Okay, how about that? Let's go ahead and let's
listen to it and see what was said. Uh, it's not defamation.
Well, no, I'll watch it. It's okay. >> Criticizing the
rightwing. Think about if the shoe was on other foot. Now, this
brother comes along. I don't know. >> Isn't Isn't that
defamation? I mean, we haven't even watched the claim yet.
Is is click baiting in the uh in the I guess title of your stream
or the title of your segment? Is that is that defamation? Maybe.
>> I feel like he probably just said this. >> Who
is uh I mean people say maybe that he's got a following, but
I've never heard of him. Right. Okay. And his and his co conspirator
Jagger Meister or whatever, right? >> Yeah. I don't even
know who's I don't even know who Jaggermeister is. Actually,
I do. He was a guy in my guild. He's a death knight in my guild
in World of Warcraft.
Wow. As gold and Jaggermeister. I have no idea what Chen was
trying to say there. Does anybody know? I don't know what he
was going for. That's like a swing and a miss right there. >> And
you definitely don't know who he is. So, I don't know who he
I don't know which Jaggermeister he's talking about. >> This
guy's talking about Oh, yeah. Run over protesters. I don't mind
it. He said, "Yes." >> So, you don't mind extreme violence
running over somebody with a car? Okay. >> Well, yeah.
If they block your road, yeah, absolutely. If they don't let
you try to get by and they crowd your car, I think you absolutely
should be able to run them over. And you can see how and and
this is what I think Listen,
if they crowd your car, if you feel like if you have a significant
reason to think that they could be like hurting you, maybe.
But I don't know. It's just it's really easy to like
to differentiate the lines here, right? No, no, no. I'm saying
there are cases where I've seen somebody, you know, they're driving,
they're trying to slowly move through a crowd, right? And the
the crowd starts like surrounding and trying to like flip the
car. They're trying to like break the windows, right? At that
point, unfortunately,
that is the time you make like a business decision. Yeah. I don't
know that you make a business decision at that point,
right? But I don't unfortunately I don't think Asmin Gold's ever
clear. And like this isn't really what Tom Cotton was saying.
And if I remember Asmin Gold's take during the Tom Cotton thing,
he's like, "Yeah, yeah, you should be able to just run these
people over." It's like,
"Ah, man. I get it." Okay. I get how you could think this. It's
like, oh well, if a couple of these people get hit, maybe they'll
stop protesting in roadways. I think protesting in roadways should
be illegal. Like, if you are protesting directly in the roadway,
I think that should probably be illegal. Where people walk is
fine. Protesting in a roadway, especially like a highway, highways
for sure have to be illegal. Like, like literally, okay, but
people need to actually be like arrested and and held accountable,
right, for those things.
No, no, no, no, no, no. The revolution will be illegal. Okay.
re I hope you understand. Okay, this is totally fine. You want
to say that it's going to be revolution and revolution will be
illegal, right?
If you want to say that, that's fine. But then don't get mad
when this guy's like, I want to do illegal [__] to
those people doing illegal [__] right? Oh yeah, like
this is really Don't say, oh no, I want the laws to protect me
while I'm doing this like very illegal thing that clearly is
dangerous as in protesting on a highway,
right? Don't act like Don't act like that wasn't something that
could possibly happen. It's one of those gray areas where it's
like, yeah, there's a lot of things I expect to happen here and
it's not going to work out well for either side,
right? And I don't want you to complain.
Is very funny about this is that people like this always like
misrepresenting. This is why I don't debate with people. It's
because they're just liars.
Like you can't debate and argue. >> So illegal, I mean
more illegal. I mean, as in if you are blocking a major roadway
for a long period of time, like
I'm fine with inconveniencing people. I'd like people to mostly
protest at like near or approximately to the thing they're protesting
and inconvenience those people.
That's personally what I like to see >> And you know, have
a conversation with a person whenever they're not operating on
the same wavelength as you are. So when you have somebody like
Jenk who's saying like, "Oh, well, you know, you're just trying
to run over protesters, etc." You're you're not even trying to
engage with the conversation. You're not even trying to understand
the point of view that I'm putting forward. You're intentionally
misunderstanding it in order to make an uh Yes. Uh, actually,
actually, Sausage, my take on the Trudeau thing was that they
needed to go in with tear gas and and clubs and beat the out
of those people. Beat the out of those truckers, like horribly,
okay, and move them forcibly. That that was my opinion through
that whole thing. Yes, they took way too long to do that.
But that's different. that's sitting on a major trade route that
was actually with the economy of both countries significantly.
Okay, that's like basically they were like the Houthies. Okay,
that's Canada's version of the Houthies right there. They're
like, "Oh, if we park our trucks and start blocking this roadway
that we all drive across and know exactly how much cargo goes
over this bridge, right, then uh get get like we win."
That's like that was crazy. And those people needed to be cleared
out
like that that could not that was not allowed. So protesting
bad when effective. Uh yes. Yes. Obviously protesting bad when
effective,
Like like the most effective protest would be a literal revolution
where you overthrow the government. That doesn't mean it's good.
What What did the truckers want? Do we know what the truckers
wanted?
Were the truckers doing anything productive at all?
>> An argument which is like that's fine. You want to do
that. go ahead and do that, but that doesn't mean that I'm going
to take it seriously. Okay. So, let's go back moving goalpost.
Yeah. Yeah. I I clearly was not talking about any protester.
Why would I think that you I mean like what is the what is the
logic here?
>> But you know what? Why don't we instead
>> I don't even hold on. Point of protest should be against
the government. It's not even that you can protest against private
citizens. You can protest whatever you want. I'm saying that
if you are trying to add people to your mob by ruining the lives
or or livelihoods or slowing them down or like making it harder
for other people to live so that they, you know, get angry as
well, you're just asking for more friction in the society. You're
just asking for the society to be like more and more angry, right?
And unfortunately, a lot of protests that happen end up happening
to like like literally it's just maximizing as much like um antipathy
as possible instead of like trying to protest and cause inconvenience
to the people who are who are like actually causing you problems.
Yeah. >> For exercising one of the most fundamental American
rights, freedom of speech. The one remember that you >> the
freedom of all pretended you were in favor of. >> Yes.
Yes. the freedom of speech, you know, like it's about, you know,
religion, uh, you know, being able to assemble, uh, freedom of
association, uh, freedom of the, uh, no, I'd say those people
are free to strike and not go to their work, um, once you start
congregating around the same area and you create like a hazard
to other people while impeding their ability to move through
somewhere, right? Like there's there's obviously like a line.
I I can't exactly pick where the line is with regards to protesting,
but there is a line where you're no longer like um
where like you are presenting problems to the rest of the society
that are outside of you just not doing your job. Right?
So, I'm fine with you not doing your job, but I'm not fine with
you not doing your job so you can go and make sure somebody else
doesn't do their job.
I'm sure this shakes out to something like the probably something
like the libertarian nap or something like this. >> The
press and also the really important one that Jin is is obviously
reminding me of is freedom of rocks. That's right. Uh so in the
first amendment it says that you know you can say whatever you
want, believe whatever you want, and also throw rocks at whoever
you want. Uh that's that's what the first amendment says uh very
clearly. And uh I don't know really what to say about this, but
that's where things go. Freedom of rocks. Yeah, rocks of speech.
>> I know some of them meant it, but apparently a lot of
them, including Asman and Jagger Meister, didn't mean it. That
they they thought, "Oh, freedom of speech for me, for me." To
say that maybe you should be murdered or be made my slave, my
freedom of speech. Good. >> Well, I mean, I don't know
why this is such a contentious topic. Like, wouldn't it be good
if we could have prisoners that are in jail and they're
in prison for 20 years doing some work so we can save money?
Like how's this even a qu how is this even a debate >> Jesus
like we used to do this for years like why why are we even debating
this at all it's obviously a good idea what are we even talking
about and so anyway did he call you he did he did call me that
and so uh I am Jagger Meister I I don't know who Jäger Meister
is at all but uh let me go back I'll see if I can >> you
should be murdered or be made my >> so yes if if I and
this is again what my perspective is I think that if you initiate
deadly force against somebody that person should be allowed to
respond with deadly force against you. So I view throwing a rock
at a person as deadly force. And so because a >> this is
like this is basically when he explains it in the lightest way,
this is something akin to what I feel like right like the what
I see a lot of protests turn into at least the ones that are
like over streets and stuff is they go to block the street and
then somebody will drive up and they'll go to like slowly roll
through
and the protesters will menace them with force, right? And so
effectively what the protest has become is like a mob that is
going to hurt anybody who tries to get through them even if they're
trying to do so peacefully and accepting like the the penalty
of being slowed down and stuff. Right. Thought you were about
to agree that the police should be able to gun down people for
throwing a rock. No, no, no, no, no, no. >> It will just
be your pain. >> I'm just saying that like
>> Reuben donated $3. Speaking of rocks, did you know that
Kaya is Turkish for rock? Everything reminds me of shock collars.
Okay, thank you very much. I did not know that. Thank you, Reuben.
Ruben, I also would have to fact check that because I feel like
you would lie in a donation just to try to hoodwink me. I feel
like that's the kind of you do sometimes.
Yeah. So anyway, if like if you're if you're basically forming
like a mob to prevent people from going a certain way, and if
they're like slowly idling through, you're you go to start like
trying to break their window and which is something I've seen
a video of like like 10 different times, then I'm like, "Oh,
you're you're now just like trying to create this mob to to threaten
other people with violence to get your way." That's so that that's
the point where to me it breaks down. You're not just doing like
peaceful whatever protesting. Uh thanks for the 100 kicks, Max.
>> Police officer is a person. I think that if you throw
a rock at a police officer, a police officer should be able to
respond with deadly force by shooting you. Uh that's my logic.
That's my reasoning. And that's also forward as seems totally
fine. Temporary temporary um bounded meant to make a statement
and not meant to basically establish like a blockade where they
can use their own threat of violence to stop other people from
moving through >> logic and Florida's reasoning. That's
exactly what Florida does. So, if you're mad at me for saying
this, that's totally okay, but you also have to understand that
there is an entire state in our >> uh by the way, like
I I literally only think the cars should be able to like speed
or something or like go through. I only feel like you could possibly
justify that in the case where they are trying to like peacefully
idle through to get wherever they're going, right? And then they're
met with like force. People are like trying to break their windows
or they're trying to like stop the car, flip the car over. Yeah.
all these things in our country uh that has the exact same viewpoint
on this than I do. Don't try to act like I'm some extreme radical
or some crazy person when there are states with millions of people
in it that agree with this. They and I think that most people
agree with this too at a very fundamental level. Like if somebody
threw a rock at Jen Uger, I would say that if you wanted to that
guy, go ahead. Like if somebody's
probably not. Probably not. Probably not. I I guess you could
maybe maybe you could say you
maybe you could say that you
uh what could you say here? Maybe like if it was like somebody
throwing a rock off of a high place trying to kill Shank. I don't
I don't know. There's maybe some way. But if it's like what we
all think of, you know, a protester throwing a rock that could
probably like him up but not kill him. I don't think you just
gun that guy. You can't gun that guy down.
I don't know.
I There's I haven't thought about Okay. I haven't thought about
the
the tradeoff of the rifleman versus like the slinger, okay, the
guy slinging rocks and and like how much capacity for damage
they do. Okay, he's trying to hit you in the head with a rock.
I mean, what are we talking about >> How much capacity
for damage they have? >> Why are we trying to rationalize
and justify violent aggressive behavior from people that are
trying to destroy property and accurately or sorry, actively
trying to subvert the law? Uh, that's it. Nobody wants to have
rocks thrown at them. Nobody wants to have anything like this
happen to them. It's insane that we should expect police officers
to be punching bags. It's unfair to them. It's entitled to the
people who are angry. And it's also just the wrong thing to do.
Like this is the thing with me is that I'm actually the only
person to care. Wait, I thought it was committed with a jawbone.
Love the pie. Was it not a jawbone? That was the jawbone of Was
it a jawbone of an axe?
Am I crazy?
>> About doing the right thing, but a lot of other people
don't. It's sad to see, but that's where we're at. >> My
freedom of speech. Good. And by the way, I wouldn't cancel that.
I don't mind him saying the terrible things that he says. Now
we know who he is. >> So, and I'm not afraid of his speech.
I'm not afraid that the majority of Americans are going to look
at that and go, "Oh, yeah. I think we should instead of having
freedom of speech, if anyone >> they did. That's why they
voted for
>> They did. They did agree with me. That's why they voted
for him. He was that he was saying this himself.
>> Freedom of speech in a way that I don't like politically.
We should arrest them. Take away all their rights. Make sure
they can't vote. You can see how I don't know why there's so
much obfuscation that goes around with this topic. And actually,
I'm saying that, but that's not true. I do know exactly why.
So, basically, every time that I talk about how police should
deal with any sort of rioter or somebody being violent towards
them, everybody that is against this always tries to shift the
conversation about protesting as if protesting includes violence.
as if protesting includes destroying property and throwing rocks
at people and uh you know throwing fireworks at them. Uh the
fact is that that's never what protest >> I think so I
think Asmin Gold's got a point here uh in terms of optics that
like there is a line that some of these protests cross where
people no longer feel bad and they do want the law to intervene.
This is correct. Right. The thing that's overt Republicans right
now, I think, is the detaining of citizens who are not engaging
in these activities, like them doing them doing like insane
like fascist
grabs of people off the street of like they're like random citizens
like this fat old woman who got grabbed in Chicago just recently,
right? They're just they're just going to snatch her off the
street for like possibly throwing a water bottle at their vehicle,
but they like tackle her to the ground,
right? It's like there's no real property damage there. She's
not a real threat. you don't have the same arguments, right,
with a with a lone citizen that you'd have in the in the case
with like a big
>> was that's never what it has been and that's not what
it should be and it's never what it will be. And the fact is
that whenever people do this, they intentionally try to misunderstand
an argument and you have to understand why are they misunderstanding
the argument. The reason why they're misunderstanding it is because
they don't want to understand it because they can't argue against
the actual argument. They can only argue against the straw man
of the argument because any reasonable person would come to the
very obvious conclusion that yes, if somebody is initiating deadly
force against you, you should be able to defend yourself with
deadly force. This is obviously the case. But for whatever reason,
you know, they're not willing to accept that. And the reason
why they don't want to accept that is because they want rocks
thrown at police officers.
>> So here, hold on. There's this McKenna person's point
putting something out like this is what you need to see from
Asmin Gold is basically okay now when Ice is doing this in like
clearly incorrect situations. What's your reaction to it? Right?
Like we'd need to see how Asminold reacts to like individual
citizens like happening to them where they don't pose anywhere
near the same risk to anybody and the cops are taking them down
cuz in my opinion those are like the opposite and those are having
the opposite effect where where they see some of this stuff happening
like neutral or or middle you know centrist people nonpartisan
people see this happening they're like oh I voted for this uh
whoops whoops
loves that clip of the woman getting tackled. Well, there's a
chance that that clip was something he looked at today. Take
a look. >> It's because they want property to be destroyed.
It's because they want this chaos because this chaos feeds into
the narrative that Trump is creating the chaos when it's in fact
not. >> I don't think this is like a group of people that
actually exist. And I notice I actually noticed this probably
do I know I feel like I notice this more from the um from like
liberal commentators than Republican ones normally. just this
framing of like, oh, they want this. I feel like
I probably just watch more liberal commentators, but this is
something that people do a lot. And it's like, bro, I don't think
anybody just wants people getting shot or like stuff getting
burned down. I don't think I don't think there's a single person
who really wants that. I don't think there are like evil people
like that. At least not to any major extent.
I don't know. I I feel like this is always this always strikes
me as uh
oh, it's not populism. It's just like it's using people's emotions
to rile them up. Like it's it's not an actual argument. It's
not based on anything people say. It's like when you see Trump
doing this actually right now with Chuck Schumer and the shutdown.
Chuck said, "Well, you know what? Like the shutdown sucks, but
I guess it's like better for us." like people blame people totally
I was going to say jingoism but I think that's more of a on a
like nationalistic
identity axis but um but he he says about Chuck Schumer Chuck
Schumer says okay well the shutdown's going good for us people
blame Republicans right they blame Republicans and I mean I guess
we'll keep going until the Republicans want it to stop and Trump
takes like the oh this is good for us or something and he's like
well despite Chuck Schumer saying that he wants the government
shut down and he wants America at risk of any invasion because
we can't pay our soldiers despite the the communist Democrats
wanting all these things. The radical left-wing Democrats. Okay,
despite them wanting all these things is a truth social I can't
even do the I can't even pretend to know the writing style anymore.
Hold on. Give me a second. Let me see if I can pop this up.
Real Donald Trump. Where is this?
There it is. I'll just I'll just read it. Chuck Schumer recently
said every day gets better during their radical left shutdown.
I disagree. If nothing is done because of the leader Chuck Schumer
and the Democrats, because of leader Chuck Schumer and the Democrats,
our brave troops will miss the paychecks. They right they are
rightfully due on October 15th. That is why I'm using my authority
as commander-in-chief to direct our Secretary of War, Pete Hegith,
to use all available funds to get our troops paid on October
15th. We have identified funds to do this, and Secretary Hexith
will use them to pay our troops.
I will not allow the Democrats to hold our military and the entire
security of our nation hostage with the their dangerous government
shutdown. The radical left Democrats should open the government
and then we can work together to address healthcare and many
other things that they want to destroy. Thank you for your attention
to this matter. President Donald J. Trump, Donald J. Trump, President
of the United States. It's like, bro, it doesn't that's
that's like not even This is not like Chuck Schumer's
sentiment at all. He's saying like politically, I guarantee Chuck
Schumer wants the government running. So anyway, I just I don't
like this whenever I see this this thing of like, oh, they they
want you they want you dead. Okay, it's probably just never true.
Somebody tells you that, right? It's just never true. >> Not
the case. Trump is not creating the chaos. People are creating
thea people are creating the chaos because they don't like what
Trump is doing the chaos which is a very different thing and
so
>> everybody knows this by the way everybody knows there's
like so many euphemisms for well there are several euphemisms
I could think of one you know the euphemism like you can't win
an argument that as soon as things turn confrontational as soon
as you're arguing with somebody you can't like convince them
to your side there's like a very similar thing that happens with
um just trying to dictate what people can do and what they say
like when there's protests over stuff, the reason people have
gone to sort of like evaluating and containing protests is because
if you meet protests with significant force that causes more
people to go to the protest to engage in the exact activity you
want to minimize,
right? And so you have to constantly do this calculation and
people who decide that they can overcome doing that calculation
just through sheer force,
it never ends up going well. It just always ends up going poorly
for you every single time. It's called reactants. >> That's
why they want to silence them. Exactly. And so for them, and
this is where I find to be so interesting, and I'm not saying
that Jinx says this at all, but this is a very common thing that
you know, leftwing people do, is that they say that certain types
>> Oh, it is called reactants. Yes, that literally is it.
Yeah.
Hold on. I didn't even I'd never heard this term before. In psychology,
reactance is an unpleasant motivational reaction to offers, persons,
rules, regulations, advice, recommendations, information, and
messages that are perceived to threaten or eliminate specific
behavioral freedoms. As in, in you are coercing me into doing
something. And I can see that you're coercing me into doing it.
And now it's gross. Now it's gross. Okay.
Trump Trump literally can't even run a country without giving
off vibes. Okay. It's impossible for him.
of words or violent rhetoric and violent speech and should be
spoken down about. But also, whenever they're actually being
violent, well, they think that's just freedom of speech. And
it's like this weird inversion of logic that you see happen everywhere
where you have some people that are talking about freedom of
speech, but then they're being violent. They think that violence
is speech and they also think that speech is violence. It's like
a complete inversion
of logic, reality, rationality, and priorities. And again, you
would think that so I don't think here's the thing is people
basically just have a difference of opinion on where
on like what they consider
most important. Oh, how could I there's a way to describe this.
So
people have a difference of opinion on what their like first
principle is. Like there are people who want maximal freedom
but but like while they want maximal freedom, they do it within
like some decision-making matrix where they like they don't want
people to get hurt, right? They want maximum freedom to protest
and stuff, but they don't want rocks thrown at people, right?
Once once like rocks are getting thrown and somebody's getting
hurt, they probably are like, "Oh, no, no, no. Somebody should
do something now, like it has to be contained or dispersed or
whatever." Right? That's most people. Nobody's like I I've never
heard somebody who's like, "No, no, no. I need to defend these
ability these people's ability to throw rocks at cars or rocks
at other people. I've never heard that, right?
But there are people who are like, well, if if we if the choice
is like a couple rocks getting thrown or a couple skulls getting
cracked by police batons, then I choose a couple rocks, right?
Yeah. They'd agree on the point of dis on diminishing returns
or they they they disagree on like the
on
what situation should be prioritized,
like once it gets to a middle ground that it usually gets to,
they're like, "Well, the excesses of one side offend me less
than the excesses of the other side." You ever pay your rent
in cash? This that [__] feels violent.
>> Uh, no. But also, no, I don't I've never had that feeling.
But cool. >> This doesn't make sense. But whenever you
look at it from the perspective of these people are only saying
these things because these things are beneficial to them and
their world view or their point of view then everything else
about it makes perfect sense because it's not actually about
>> oh hold on hold on hold on here's on how he views anyone
on the left. I'm sure he has a fair view on their right to
>> What is this froggy tonic tweet? >> It's fine.
Sorry the left is so toxic. No, it's it doesn't bother me. Like
uh there's plenty of people that use that kind of stuff against
me. Like I I really um I don't This is going to sound really
bad. I don't even really view them as people. I don't I view
them as like animals. And so whenever an animal gets angry at
me, like a dog barks at me, do I really think to myself, am I
doing something wrong? Am I a bad person when a dog is barking
at me? Or
>> this guy used a Ratford alarm clock, a dead the dead
corpse of a rat for an alarm clock. and he's looking at you and
you're like, "You don't respect our civil liberties." And he's
like, "That person's like an animal. That person is like is like
a bacterium to me. That person is like a bacterium." Okay.
Uh,
amazing. Moon hisses at me. No, I just think to myself, it's
a stupid dog. It's a What do you expect? And so, I don't even
really think about them as people. And that's really the reason
I that that's that's why it doesn't bother me. I'm sorry to say.
A painter used to think the same. Really? Um, listen,
>> dude. That's actually hilarious that he got called on
that instantly.
Uh, talking about Van Go, obviously. Van Go, Van Go, Van Go,
Van Go. >> The only difference between me and most people
is that I say it. >> Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
I need something that gives me a Twitter overlay. Listen,
the only difference between me and most people is that I say
it. >> Yeah, that's
that's funny. Okay,
that's funny. Listen
listen.
Yeah, there are a lot of people like me and yeah, I do believe
these things and yeah, I say them like he can he weaves. It's
like, how do I put this? He somehow weaves perfectly to like
not quite get cancelled and also maximize rage bait. Like there
is something here where
he's like
and I know I know there will be people who really push back against
this. He's like a slightly
less
conspiracy Candace Owens where he's like figuring out very it's
not just a Mott and Bailey though. It's not just that he's like
tapped into a lot of other cultural things going on and just
he can like very easily figure out exactly where to go to make
the clip at any given moment in time. He's like very It's like
It's an actual skill that he does this on the fly on a stream.
Like think about how other rage baiters like this have to operate.
They just go and they they they like they do their if they if
they stream at all, it's like not the same. And then they do
videos and they make claims like this and then they get the rage
bait. This guy is like perfectly doing it in the moment on the
fly with like every clip he does. And he does like he does like
five clips a day that are like this.
I think I think there's a skill to it. Um, not to say it's like
a good skill that somebody should practice or anything like that.
It's obviously not a great skill. It's just uh it's there's something
to it that's like it's not just moronic. He's not just fluking
his way into it. He's doing something I think deliberate that
is leading to like this success and him doing these clips every
other day.
Oh boy. Anyway,
it's not, by the way, if if any of that sounded like I think
it's respectable, it's really not. It's really not respectable,
okay?
About any sort of principle. It's not about any logic. It's not
about being rational. It's about creating and, you know, having
a conclusion and then reverse engineering a justification in
order to make it to where the conclusion that you got to is okay.
And that's what's happening here. And I think that these people
are really it's it's so obviously dishonest, it's unbelievable.
Uh I I'm surprised that so many people buy into this, but it's
>> uh his dad is like a university professor. He's not
stupid. Well, I'm not. That's what I'm literally saying. A lot
of people say he's just really dumb, but that's not the case.
It's like never been the case. >> Extremely common nowadays.
It really is.
Should stop letting stuff slide. Oh, no. I I know. I'm just saying
that like this is a uh uh this is exactly what's happening. And
like I'm not going to sue anybody. Like what? I don't want to
sue somebody. Like it's crazy. Not I don't even think I could
to be honest with you. But the point is that these people intentionally
misrepresent what's being said all the time. And they do so because
they can't argue against the actual fact and what's actually
being said. They can argue only argue against a straw man of
it >> and then turn them into slaves. No. 98% of Americans
are going to be against >> That's not true.
I think most people agree with me. They do. They might not know
it, but they do.
and more people will agree with me every single year. It's going
to become more and more >> But man thinks that's a great
idea. So he's like for freedom of speech unless it's leftwingers.
How dare they protest our government. Let's take away all their
rights. Did you see what they he said? Make sure they can't ever
vote >> Of course. >> Jesus Christ. Uh Chank does
keep calling him a man over and over again. Yes, that is. You're
not misharing that. It's definitely man over >> and that's
another component too. Do you want, and you know, ask yourself
the question for this, do you want a violent political extremist
that's trying to throw rocks and attack people be the person
who is deciding the fate for the country? I don't. I don't. And
I I'm so sick of this fake Hold on. Hold on. We actually have
to go back to this this Chank bit here cuz uh this is this is
some salient uh this is a salient thought here from Glowing Pear.
Hold on. Let's listen to this again. Chank is slowly turning
into Alex Jones. >> Yeah. So, he's like, "All right, I'm
for freedom of speech. Unless it's left-wingers. How dare they
protest our government? Let's take away all their rights." Did
you see what they he said? Make sure like was that was that an
I don't think that was a Alex Jones impression.
Maybe he just like latently in his brain thinks about Alex Jones
and was like, "Oh, I'm going to do an Alex." Maybe
like I I think he was just like rolling. He was just like riffing.
Yeah.
That's very funny. >> They can't ever vote again. And >> of
course, exactly. And that's another component, too. Do you want,
and you know, ask yourself the question for this, do you want
a violent political extremist that's trying to throw rocks and
attack people, be the person who is deciding the fate for the
country? I don't. I don't. And I I'm so sick of this fake reality
that we have to pretend to live in that it's actually a good
thing that every [__] and his mother can vote on
things. This is a huge problem. It's become a huge issue. And
by the way, if anybody's saying this isn't American, well, this
is what the Constitution used to say. Most people weren't allowed
to vote back then. And you know, I think this is what I think.
I think they need to have some kind of a test or some type of
massive filtering system to
>> Guys, at the start of the country, most people weren't
allowed to vote. What was the voting criteria at the beginning
of America? Was it landowners only? Cuz I remember them saying
that like land owners should be it should only be like land owners
in the Senate, right? Was it Was it only land owners got to vote
Okay. Landowning white men.
Was it? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Male white land owners.
Did it say white in the constitution? Did it say property white
men?
Did it did it really say that? Is that like what the what did
the constitution say when it granted like suffrage to people?
Okay. So it was it was exclusionary. Okay. So the constitution
didn't say that. It was just that like they said land owners
and they wouldn't even sell land to anybody else.
Right. So like by by exclusion by the thing by the people they
excluded it was only white male land owners like those are the
only things that existed.
Um okay interesting stop people from voting because there is
a huge amount of people that are voting for the >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry I'm what I'm trying to understand is
did America go through like constitutional amendments to
to change that? Were they written with those things? Like were
those things written down or were they letting like cultural
norms dictate how they excluded people or did they actually explicitly
try to write them down was what I was wondering cuz cuz it seems
like basically man it would be really hard to defend the the
founding fathers if they went through like
the whatever the articles were to like found the country and
then they're like yeah we need to make sure that no other race
can ever vote here. I just feel like that's outside of like I
expected those people to be sort of like thinkers that while
racist would be racist as a matter of like cultural norm rather
than racist as like a matter of logical thought
>> or some mix of both. But like I I kind of feel like
the idea of being able to defend them in their ideas up until
this point is that they weren't they were racist as a matter
of like this is the norm of the time rather than they were like
oh we need to just like totally
right make sure this is a white nation. like it's a a different
kind of racism. I don't know. I was just in my head it it seems
like a distinction I'd like to know. Also, Slime 712, thank you
for the gifted sub. Thank you. Thank you.
So, Asmin Gold is saying we need to cut out most people from
owning land and somebody says that's unamerican.
I think there's a Listen, I think if you basically want to go
to oh well, we shouldn't do one person one vote and that's that's
like American cuz we didn't do that originally. I think people
realize pretty quickly that that was like not a good way to set
up a country, right? Like unless you just think because here's
the thing, Asmin presents himself as the man of the people. And
I've asked like about how he would cut it down. I think some
of his supporters said, "Oh, it should be like an IQ test or
something." It's like, okay, you could do that, but then if the
IQ test cuts out a significant portion of the high earning population,
your tax base would just leave, right? Why is somebody going
to sit in America paying taxes to America if they're like a business
owner?
Why wouldn't they go set up their business? Why wouldn't they
go set up their income in another place,
right? And if it's not if it's if it's just going to be income,
then if you want to prioritize saving your tax base, then are
you just arguing that like we should let the elites win? Cuz
if you only let the 20 top like 5 10 15% of of earners vote,
then you're going to be eating the bugs. I don't know if you
know this, but like that's going to skew Democrat like 8020.
that's going to reset your entire country. Just so you
So like how is he the man of the people if he's arguing for that?
I don't get it.
I don't get how he like justifies this belief at all. Used to
say most people weren't allowed to vote back then. And you know
I think this is what I think. I think they need to have some
kind of a test or some type of massive filtering system to stop
people from voting because there is a huge amount of people that
are voting for the dumbest possible reasons. and it's not a benefit
to anybody else. So yeah, only 12% of the country votes. I think
it's more than that. It it's probably like
that can't possibly be. I think electoral participation is like
45% to 55% or something, right, in American
But there's no way 12%. Could you imagine? Could you imagine?
>> Like 30 something% 40 high 30, low 40% chance. And really,
I mean, anybody would agree with this. It's obviously true that
you don't want to have people that are completely uneducated
vote. So, if you don't want to have like, what's the logic?
>> Why can't 16-year-olds vote, right? Well, 16-year-olds
can't vote because they are not educated and they don't know
what the [__] going on, right? Why can't felons vote
in a lot of cases? Well, it's because they have proven themselves
to be violent members of society. And you don't want to have
that type of a person deciding where society is going because
they're not of a sound mind or not of, you know, proper moral
character. So all I'm saying is that we apply those same rules.
I actually don't know if you I feel like it's borderline and
I I believe this is backed up that it's like not exactly settled
constitutional understanding that you can strip somebody's vote
for being a felon, right? As far as I know, that's like kind
of still up in the air and there isn't really a hard ruling on
that being a thing, is there? Although, actually, in my head,
now that I think about it, I think I think you lose a lot of
rights when you commit crime. I think you lose like a right.
>> I will just be your pay.
>> Reban Ruben donated $3. First IQ question should be
asking, which is an alarm clock? A picture of an alarm clock
or a picture of a rat's corpse?
Thank you for the donation, Reben Rubin. Yeah, that would be
a good one. Did you see the Reuben Rubin donation?
Okay. Okay. Good stuff. Um
I understand that it's state- based. Okay. States have some restrictions.
So, it's not a like a constitutionally settled question cuz I
think it it it has to be borderline unconstitutional because
it it seems like you're deciding that all felons lack moral character.
that seems to fly in the face of like any idea of rehabilitative
justice, of like of forgiveness, of like so many things. I don't
know. I feel like um yeah, I understand when you're an outlaw,
you issue many of the protections, but then like once you're
out, I'm talking about like once you're out of being incarcerated,
I feel like there's probably a good constitutional argument for
you not being able to have your vote stripped anymore.
Uh you have you have not right to actually vote in the constitution
at the end of the individual level. at the end of the individual
level is just requires some level of democratic process but there
is not explicit right to vote in the constitution. Oh, okay.
Interesting.
Never looked that up. Oh, okay. Yeah. Again, this is one of those
cases where um where I don't take like your your sort of like
civics or social studies classes. I've never taken them. So,
probably a lot of like, you know, you'd expect it to be just
common knowledge that wouldn't be talked about a lot. I might
not necessarily know.
Yeah, I kind of assumed that one person one vote would have been
sort of enshrined because how did they decide how did they go
from then how did they go from uh land owners to everybody gets
a vote? How did they dictate that? Um
Oh, was it was it basically like not once they disute once they
disallowed slavery that would have in that would have put a bunch
of them uh that would have granted suffrage to a bunch of them,
right? Okay. I It's fine. >> To people that are throwing
rocks at police officers. That's that's really all there is to
it.
>> Did I not set a timer? I didn't even set a timer and
I haven't even reset the the meters at all. What What am I doing
my life, guys? What am I doing? Why didn't anybody tell me what's
going on? It's very simple. What the >> I don't know if
his followers were like, "What an idiot. We set freedom of speech,
dumbass." Okay. Or if they're like, "Yeah, yeah, we hate freedom
of speech now. Now that we're in charge, let's turn them into
slaves."
Are 13 people watching that show? Who would like them a little
bit more? that kind >> Oh, Chank is Chank Chank does this
a couple times like talks about how small Asmin Gold's audience
is. And it's very very funny that he's like so unaware of who
Asmin is. Like Asmin's arguably larger than Hassan is. And I
guarantee you Trunk's like argument for why Hassan should be
in most conversations politically, why he deserves like a spot
at the DNC and stuff is going to be the size of Hassan's audience,
right? >> That's very funny. monstrously unamerican
piece of crap like that. Who doesn't believe in >> unamerican?
How is it unamerican whenever America was founded and only like
probably like 10% of the population could vote? Like it was only
wealthy white land owners that could vote at the beginning of
America. So how are you going to dictate to what America is whenever
America and I'm not even I'm not okay. So Asagold is arguing
that if we reinstituted slavery that would not be unamerican.
Don't you know guys there was slavery at the beginning of America.
How could it possibly be unamerican to have slavery? How could
you possibly consider reinstituting the slavery? How could you
slavery? We're going to reinstitute it. That's not
Oh, wow. Okay. Advocating for that, by the way. I'm not. And
I don't think that's a good way to base things. There's plenty
of stupid rich white people that I don't think should vote. The
problem is that really that dumb people are voting. It's not
about their skin color. It's about their mind. And this is really
what it's it's just it's so stupid to have you know what is America
dictated to you by somebody who I mean what are we talking about?
This isn't the way America was started at
>> America at all. >> Um I mean I don't consume content
like this. I can't imagine that.
Um, I think like as you if you are somebody who believes in like
American values, I would assume you have to believe in the idea
of having a like living constitution and a mutable structure
to your values in government and that what being American is
is what your like constitutional what your constitution says,
what your bill of rights says. Like those are the American ideals
like and and the idea that that is mutable and the idea that
that changes over time and updates over time is incredibly
>> Asen got gold what? Whatever >> it's Freudian
slip
happens a lot. >> Did you catch that? Did you catch that
>> content like this? I can't imagine that as God. What?
Whatever. >> It's Freud. >> Oh, is she actually is
she actually a secret Asmin Gold viewer? Okay.
Oh, dude.
>> Nothing. Nothing. >> Happens a lot.
>> Okay, I'm just gonna say if you guys have ever done
the challenge of like dropping into any city in India and trying
to look for any clean area that doesn't have just garbage strewn
all over the ground, uh, Indian women may be uniquely situated
to be partners of Asminold. Okay. Growing up in the mean streets
of Mumbai might be the only thing that could prepare you to live
in Asminold's home.
I'm just saying that's like that's just facts. Okay.
I'm just telling you that has to be that is just >> Yeah.
I mean stuff like that happens all the time. >> Yeah. She
I mean she knows. Yeah.
>> His name is I can't imagine that he is watching the
show right now either.
>> Listen with the amount of viewers you guys get, I can
see why you say that. But somehow I managed to find it. >> Flip
the viewership argument. Goddamn. >> And uh you know uh
what a good thing for me. What great content. And uh yeah, people
trying to farm you again, man. It's normal. I know. I know. It's
very funny for me to see this, but you have a lot of people that
feel this way. A lot of people that are hyperaggressive about
this stuff. And again, I think it's funny to see people like
this crash out. But also, I mean, this is just how things like
this are. You can't farm farmer. I mean, yeah. And so you're
getting so mad. And what I find to be so interesting and so surprising
about this topic is that everybody in this entire uh in this
entire debate here is completely misrepresenting what I said.
It it there's not even an a there's not even an attempt to understand
what's being discussed. It's all just [__] Yeah.
Look at this here. Guess the song complained to his uncle. I
don't know about this, >> dude. Dude, there's so much clout
for being on Asigold's side that this guy just bleeds off massive
amounts of clout, like insane amounts that if you're going to
go to Twitter and just start defending this guy, you can make
so much money. You can get so many viewers like every time. It's
crazy. >> And is tattling on Asmin? I have no idea. 0%
Jinx. Jinx never hold of Asmin gold while son being his nephew.
A dumb thing to lie about. I don't know whether he has or not
but I think it's very funny. So uh yeah
and uh many such cases McKenna Chenna Chank can definitely Chank
is really good in a debate. He's really good to get like the
emotional points of any argument out like he is he he's very
good at uh at like conveying his emotions to the audience, right?
But he will get emotional and he'll way overplay whatever actual
factual point he's trying to make. And he does it a lot. And
it does make it very easy to like look at Chank's arguments,
the things he's saying, and go, "Oh, that's not exactly what
I said."
So yeah, I don't know. It's like a It's like a strength and a
weakness as a commentator. And he I don't know. He built like
a pretty big channel based on that. I find it funny this happens
after nephew shots his dog on stream. Almost like it's meant
to distract people. Well, and this is what I was saying before,
too, is that a lot of people try to create false controversies
around me or around other people in order to distract from the
fact that, you know, somebody that was on their side has a controversy
themselves. And this is what happens. It's not actually about
this issue itself. It's about trying to create a smoke screen
and misdirect people away from what they're talking talking about
or thinking about. That's that's what the real goal is. That's
what the actual focus is, right? And so that's it. It's obuscation.
Yes. Exactly. And uh so
and uh do you think uh just remember if you don't like what's
being said, change the conversation, crash out. Yeah, I guess
so. Yeah. Just make the whole thing up. Just only produce more
viewers and fans for you. Well, that that's I mean that's my
viewpoint on all of this stuff, right? Is that if somebody is
going to go around and do this stuff, Piers Morgan uh context
you respond to be on a show? Maybe. Yeah, I I I as I said, I
don't like really I don't like doing a lot of like live debates,
arguments, stuff like that with people. I'm just not a big fan
of it. I I I really just don't like it. And I think that this
is the clip that I just showed is a really great example of why
I don't like it. Uh the reason why I don't like it is because
you're playing by you're playing against people that are not
playing by the same rules that you are. uh these are people that
will just lie about >> ah I I totally understand like why
he says this and I think this is like a there's like parts of
this that are valid, right? There are parts of this that are
valid. Like there would be a lot of people who just want to paint
him badly and would be super bad fa and like totally like like
there'd be no reason to engage with them, right? But that also
what comes with that is I'm sure there would be people who could
engage with him in good faith and make him look kind of dumb
for the things he says and that
and he like lumps those things together, right? Just the the
fact that like Chen goes and says he wants people to be turned
into slaves. Like that gives him some cover to go, oh look how
it's I see this pattern a lot, right? This like hyperbole. You
show your audience the the most hyperbolic versions of your haters
and you say, "This is why I don't do like some behavior I'm not
very good at or something or some behavior that would like cost
me clout, make me look bad." And it's like, "No, that's not why
you you don't do it." Cuz you know, you're kind of just preaching
and and you can't defend a lot of the things you say. That's
why you're doing it. Like you don't have to you don't have to
make it up, man.
I get it.
I get I get what you're doing about you. They'll make things
up. Oh, so Pirate Software, you don't know what that means. So,
Pirate Software when he got when he got into controversy about
the uh the ManageMem stuff, him him roaching out in that raid.
He would show somebody somebody like messaged him and said like,
"I hope keep yourself safe at the next TwitchCon, man. I'm going
to come for you." Somebody like threatening to him basically,
but it was clearly like a brand new account that was just made
to harass him. And it was one person. He's like, "This is why
I don't engage with any of the criticism because these are who
the critics are. These are like the people who criticize me."
And it's like, no, whole bunch of people have actual legitimate
criticism for you that you totally discount cuz there's one skitso
who's going to come on like uh World of Warcraft and threaten
you. Like that's that's weird. It's just a weird argument to
make. Okay. They won't even try to engage with your argument.
Uh you know, and and that's it. And so that's really the reason
why uh that that's the reason why it's an issue. That's the reason
why I don't engage with it. Yeah. They mistake volume for validity.
Well, I I think that I don't think that's even really the case.
I I I think it's honestly just people make [__] up
about you and that's it. So, yeah, there you go. You don't have
to debate. Just be a don't be a like Don Lemon. I mean, I don't know.
I mean, Don Lemon's an idiot, but yeah. I mean, you can see everybody
in the chat is like just, you know, this guy's a idiot, right?
I mean, everybody thinks that. So, yeah, it's really just that
simple. It's a one-on-one convo with peers most likely. Ask clarification.
Yeah, maybe. I don't I don't know. I'd have to go back and look
at it and see. So, yeah. And uh instead of misrepresenting you
on DOD, they're misrepresenting your du face. Yeah. And it it's
about the debates aren't about changing the mind of the person
you're debating. They're about changing the mind of the people
that are watching the debate. And I think because of that, it's
one of the reasons why I don't like doing it. And I'm also just
not extremely quickwitted. I'm I'm not I'm really not. And uh
I I don't that's it's not a strength of mine. And so I think
you could easily have like conversations with people. You just
need to not have it be like in a super heated context. And that's
the problem with like a lot of politics. Like you could he could
easily have go and have a conversation with somebody who like
didn't hate him to his core, but unfortunately with the way he
engages in politics, there just aren't a lot of people who are
equipped to have the conversation with him and don't like hate
him to their core. So it would be it would probably be, you know,
in terms of maximizing your clout, maximizing your influence,
I do think it' probably be bad for him to actually go and debate
people. But it I don't know. It's like uh he adds like another
point in here as if like um as if like he can't be or his arguments
are correct and just nobody will engage with them correctly which
I don't think is happening at all. So because it's not a strength
of mine I don't want to uh to play into it. Right. >> Oh
do you still stand by your take this is likely why Piers still
brings on Destiny?
Um I mean I think
I think there's a different thing going on there. I don't think
this is related to that but the take I have on why Piers brings
on Destiny. Yeah. I still stand by that. >> Clearly what
it is. And uh yeah, that's all there is to it. And uh not all
debates. Yeah. VO. Yeah. And that's that's just I'm not I'm not
that type of person. And I think also, you know, I just I don't
like playing by those types of rules and saying that kind of
stuff in general, right? It's just not for me. Uh sh previous
Reddit thread, you're not talking about leftwing people, but
uh people using your parents as a as an attack point. Oh, yeah.
No. And this is and this is kind of like the point that I was
making, right? is that, you know, if you go back and you watch
the VOD of me discussing like this person, right? Whenever I
think about cuz they were saying I was dehumanizing people and
I was dehumanizing a person who was trying to weaponize the death
of my father as a reason that I have become uh crazy. Uh my dad
was crazy and I was even crazy before my dad passed away. He
even told me I should be more crazy. If anything, that was one
of his biggest criticisms of my show that like I don't go even
harder on it. So really when I see this stuff and you know this
is again people misrepresenting
and uh this is what this >> uh I do think it's like uh
>> it's a little absurd for people to say stuff like what
Vain's saying or what Slime's saying. Uh listen you guys could
say it. I I don't need to moderate you out of chat but um yeah
it's obviously not true. You guys are like swaying out. >> This
is what liars do. This is what people that are dishonest liars
do. And it's sad for me to see it but you can listen to what
I said right here. This Zagger comes back even more toxic. Oh
god, people are trying to use like my dad my dad dying against
me. Well, that's so weird. If my dad was here, he'd be saying
I'm not going hard enough.
No, no, you you don't
Yeah. Anyway, the last little bit of this is about his dad. Yeah.
I just I watched I watched a little bit of this earlier this
morning. He just had a fight with Chank. I thought it was funny
that he he basically
has a Chank clip to react to and Chen is like trying to big dog
him. He's trying to like beg him on the size of their audience
and it's like, "Oh, that's probably the only thing you can't
go after as gold for." It's like the size of his audience. His
audience is massive. This almost has a million views. It's like
random slot content that is just a clip from his stream 21 hours
ago and it's almost got a million views. Why do people think
Asmin killed his dad? Because Casey Tron said something like
2 or 3 years ago about how Asmin Gold uh his mom had like COPD
or like lung cancer or something and as she said like Asmin Gold
not cleaning his place probably led to her like lung disease
progressing faster,
right? I think I think it's something along those lines. And
then I don't think there's any argument for his dad to be honest.
So yeah. Uh and I like I feel bad for him cuz it seemed like
he had a close relationship with his dad. So, sucks when you
see somebody lose a parent that they have a close relationship
to, you know. All right. Anyway, that's the Asmin Gold segment.
I think I was going to save the Chicago Ice stuff for later,
but I kind of want to go through it now. Oh, wait. Hold on. I'm
going to do this thing first. Okay. Just Dude, everything's like
culture war stuff recently. It's very, very funny. Okay. I think
people are like the the economy stuff is so bad that we've fallen
back. Listen, like the the culture war is just the opiate of
the masses. Okay. Right now it's all culture war stuff all the
time. It's [__] crazy. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
>> All right.
Uh Veto had this fantastic segment. Okay. I feel like is on a
very similar page to me politically where it's like
or he might be a little further back from where I am where I
was like I was like pretty like I was you know moderate to like
slightly right leaning in some ways
mostly like liberal beliefs but like right leaning in some ways
feeling like culture had gone too far and seeing the way people
have like weaponized the culture war to push just the dumbest
ideas the dumbest concepts has like sort of made me skittles
out to the point that I've like completely I I'm just so repulsed
by like right-wing thought in general right now that I'm like
I'm like getting pushed super far left somehow. I don't know.
I don't know how to explain it. Like these the people who are
right-wing thought leaders are so repulsive to me that it's they're
like slightly changing they're changing my beliefs more than
I want them to. Okay. More than I think is reasonable.
>> Yeah. All right. All right. from episode 78.
You know what's coming up is the Super Bowl
where all the football goes
>> What's the best part of the Super Bowl? It's of course
the halftime show where this year >> that's not true if
you actually like football. By the way, I like the NFL for a
long time. The halftime show is so was infuriating to me. Okay,
that [__] goes on forever.
I just want to watch the football game,
Put the football game back on. >> You'll have two terrible
choices.
One, do you continue >> Puerto Rican? An illegal Puerto
Rican. Some Puerto stuttering Puerto Rican.
>> Uh, so that's the Bad Bunny reference, right? Bad Bunny,
of course, the the musical artist who's booked for the Super
Bowl halftime show. A lot of people complaining because he doesn't
do most of his music in English.
Uh, I don't know if that's fair. Uh, if he if he's a good artist,
I mean,
it could work, right?
It could work. >> Exactly. Bad Bunny has been chosen to
appear for the NFL, and many people are very upset. Uh, he made
some comment on SNL saying, "You need to learn Spanish to watch
the halftime show or whatever." >> Adios Chacho. How's
that for Spanish?
You know, I thought it was that I thought it was that uh that
catch me outside from Dr. Phil. I thought that
>> thinks it's uh Bad Baby. Okay, the the person who act
said uh wait, hold on. What's the What's the act baby tweet?
Academics Bad
Baby. Hold on. Let me find this tweet. Can I find this tweet?
Hold on. Hold on. where he
the infamous act tweet where he claims he was hacked. Okay, I
don't believe it. I don't believe it.
I don't believe he was hacked for this. Okay, but this is who
thinks is performing at the Super Bowl halftime show. I don't
even want to read it. I don't even want to read it out. Okay.
Crazy. Bad Bunny this whole time. >> Oh, really?
>> So, you heard everybody complaining about Bad Bunny.
You're like, "Well, that's kind of She's doing very well for
herself, I guess." Uh yeah, but not just for this Super Bowl.
I mean like years every time. >> Was her name Bad Bunny
also, but spelled >> I think it was Bad Bobby. Bad like
Barbie, but like >> Yeah, let's see. Boston with a Boston
>> Bad girl. I know what you're talking. >> Dude,
that H throws people. Throws >> About uh Bad Bobby.
>> I thought I thought it was bad. Thought Bad Bobby was
going to be
>> Yeah. I was like, "Huh, wow. She's come a long way.
>> She's really come a long way performing at the Super
Bowl." >> That was the first time I thought, "Wait a minute.
That's not That can't be the >> That can't be correct."
>> I'm I've been I got the wrong person, I >> Well,
if she's not performing at the Super Bowl, perhaps she'll be
performing at the exciting alternative
as provided by everyone's favorite pro-America organization,
Turning Point USA. Four slamming conservatives. That's all you
>> Erica slamming conservatives. >> Showtime spectacular.
I'm sure they'll call it the organization founded. Dude,
>> Erica Kirk and TBUSA
are running a Super Bowl halftime show alternative. Can you think
of anything more
by the late right-wing activist Charlie Kirk announced on social
media it'll be hosting its own Super Bowl halftime show Jason
Aldine. >> Well, that's what's fascinating is the website
provided for the halftime show currently has a form that aside
from personal information asks only one question. The question
is what music genres would you like to see featured?
>> Okay. Okay. Now, before you think of the music genres,
I just want to warn you. Don't think of actual music genres.
Think like if you were a corny
45year-old
man who writes for the Daily Wire was like a core writer of Lady
Ballers. All right. If you were thinking on this level,
what would you say are the genres of music? Okay. That's where
you that's where you need to go with your brain. >> Here
are the options.
Well, they're they're deciding on the website what music they're
going to play. >> Maldine, Darius Rucker,
and
I don't know, uh, Chris Christopherson. They can >> Here's
your choice. >> That's your halftime show. Yeah. >> One.
Anything in English. Haha. I get
That's the first That's the first >> Anything in English.
>> Anything in English is your first option, followed by
>> Charlie Kirk deserved it.
>> And I think that, you know, that sums up I think thoughts
on really anything in
That's the first option. >> Anything in English. >> Anything
in English is your first option. Followed by >> Charlie
Kirk deserved it. >> Stop. Americana,
classic rock,
country, hip hop.
Dude,
also I just want to laugh a little bit about how do you remember
how soy as how soy their audience got when Veto was making jokes
about Charlie Kirk like 3 weeks ago? Their audience was melting
down. And I understand it's a it's a timing thing. doing it like
the next day or the two days after is kind of crazy, but I just
I love that he was like their audience was melting the down and
then is just like there it is. I I'll give it to though. I I
understand on this. Okay, I understand that feeling. Pop and
your final pop
>> warship music is another option which could potentially
be played at the Turning Point USA football jamboree. Uh the
all-American halftime show will sell
this. These are your guys. These are your guys. Except your conservative
fellows, your conservative contemporaries.
These are your guys. These are your He's so disgusted.
There's I've never seen this guy. Listen, they've discussed some
very gross topics on this podcast. I've never seen look as disgusted
as hearing the musical genre options for the TPUSA event. Okay.
It's incredible. Point USA football jamberee. Uh the all-American
halftime show will celebrate faith, family, and freedom
and will be organized by Erica Kirk, the current CEO of Turning
Point. >> I would like Can I Can I write in I would like
Hava Nagila played
for 30 minutes straight.
>> Hold on. Hold on. We can help. We can help with that.
Okay. I've not played the song in quite a while, but yeah. Let's
go. Super Bowl halftime show. Listen,
don't say it's about family, faith, coming together. Just say,
okay, sup Turning Point USA's
not just Charlie Kirk, but his most beloved country of Israel.
Okay? In honor of the peace deal struck by President Trump, we
will be providing
mandatory pledges of allegiance to Israel. Okay? If you tune
in, you'll be able to sign a form that says you will KRD for
the state of Israel. Okay,
>> Oh, hold on. I need to shut the music off. Jesus Christ.
All right. Played that song long enough. Hadn't hadn't broken
out the song in a long time. I would like Hava Nagila played
for 30 minutes straight and a bunch of blue and white fireworks
to celebrate our allies in Israel. >> Why would they put
that [__] Did they really Wait, it didn't play. Oh,
I was hearing it on my end the whole time. Wait, are you serious?
Oh, I play, dude. I play It was playing on my end the whole time.
Hold on. Yeah, it was playing on my end the whole time. Oh, that
sucks. The
Oh, that's brutal.
Oh, I played it the whole time. That's why I was I was like going
with the music to do the bit. Oh,
brutal. Well, unlucky.
>> What as warship as one of the They hit gold. Charlie
Kirk getting assassinated is like striking oil for the TP USA.
>> It really is. They completely it. Dude, I can't stress
how true that is, right? Like they bro JD Vance identified that
instantly. JD Vance was like, "Oh yeah, Charlie Kirk, that's
like my best friend ever, and I'm going to go be on his show."
And and then I don't know what they've done since. I don't know
that I don't know that there's anything good that they've done
since. It's like striking oil for the TP USA. >> It really
is. They completely have dropped the ball >> because they
are they're just unlikable
and lame and they suck. Everybody else at that organization,
they're a bunch of barnacles and parasites. >> I look at
the turning. >> Yeah, it was, as Tequila Sunset says, it
was a oneman show. There was a guy driving that entire organization
and he built people up around him and now he's
and what can we do? Okay. What I I don't know. There's like nothing
left for them to do. >> Point I get you ask me I'm uh obsessed
with the Daily Wire cuz I look at these guys and I go, "Oh man,
you're in a position to like >> you could really capitalize
on this >> You could take over the country >> Yeah.
Yeah, >> Turning Point USA was in a position to take over
America on the back of a perfect martyr type situation. >> And
they trotted out this moonfaced beauty queen [__]
who totally let the steam out.
nobody listen.
I didn't want to say it. Okay, I think we all we all understood
that right after it happened, you had to give like you had to
give some space to Erica Kirk to feel sad. But now, like weeks
later, all right, weeks later, we can all go This is why I could
not I could not watch All right, I could not watch
any of Erica Kirk's stuff. I watched none of it cuz I I just
knew I was going to lose it completely,
right? I knew I was going to lose it completely. So, I just didn't
watch it. I was like, "No, no, people are like, "You have to
watch her. She's doing her first statement after. Nope. No thank
you. No thanks. I don't want to watch it cuz I'm going to say
some. I'm going to say some. And now now we're weeks after the
fact and we can all just let out our true feelings. >> Take
over America on the back of a perfect martyr type situation.
>> And they trotted out this moonfaced beauty queen [__]
who that totally let the steam out of >> bro. They were
basically given cart blanch to pick the next president. You could
have put any white guy up on that stage and said, "And this is
going to be the president."
>> And Charlie, vote for for Charlie. But instead, you
got this meme me fest. Instead, Miss Piggy walked out and said,
"What do we put on?
I forgive you, Go.
Once you guys are done with the football, maybe you dude." Uh
I I that Miss Piggy thing
is so accurate. Like she got like she's an attractive person.
She got the cheeks, man. She got the Miss Piggy cheeks. >> Watch
my fun show with music
and dancing and family. >> What the [__] is
Americana?
I don't know. Like that's a good >> That's like one step
above the It's like one step above like not Mexican. The first
choice. Ah, don't make me defend
>> Bad like they would say like
>> Oh, this is where Okay, this is where this is where
I'm at culturally. It's like I don't want to have to defend some
things, but holy.
Okay,
this is the version of like, yeah, just put the black elves back
in Lord of the Rings, okay? Do do all the DI you want. Just give
me back whatever was there before cuz you everybody around me
has fed this up. Every every person that I like that felt like
other things were the problem agreed with me on the problems.
They have the most solutions and I can't I can't handle listening
to them anymore. Okay, it's over. >> Born in the USA, which
is famously not really pro America song. Yeah, it's classic rock.
>> They want like they want like the soundtrack to Chevy
commercials. That's what they >> basically. Yeah. >> Yeah.
What would you like for your halftime show? Um the soundtrack
to Chevy commercials. Yes. No.
>> Where would you like Where would you like Ford commercial?
I feel like at this point they would take that uh that Bo Burnham
sketch where he does the country music thing. I think that's
what they want. They want that exact and they won't even be able
to identify the satire. They'll just be like, "Oh, that's an
awesome song. That's like a fantastic I love that song." >> Joel's
like, "I'm a Are you a Chevy guy or a Ford guy?" >> I really
can't figure out what Americana music would be because everything
I think about I go, "Well, that was black people doing it. They
don't want that.
>> Black people Mottown and Dooop and Barershop. They could
do barbershop music, I guess. I don't [__] know.
>> Like Mr. Sandman. Is that barbershop? >> Mr. Sandman.
>> I really don't want to watch the the
>> I will say, is it just like a conservative pastime now
to complain about the halftime show? Like they didn't like Kendrick's
halftime show. They're mad about Bad Bunny's halftime show. When
was the last last halftime show that they cared about and liked?
Are they just they're like, "Oh, it's like it's like uh gay pride
month, okay, but in February." Like they have something they
could complain about. Oh, it's I listen, it's that time of the
year again. The Super Bowl's coming around. Which which colored
person did they choose this time? And what crimes has anyone
around them ever committed? Please tell me. Janet Jackson.
that was memorable. That was memorable. That's true. I think
the Santana one was good. Okay. The Santana one was good. >> Why
don't you do a song about the real shooter, which they're right
now trying to find. Candace Owens is going >> Israel. Israel's
a real shooter.
>> Every
day I got to watch new >> dude. Uh I don't know if we ever
went through those tweets of Candace going back and forth to
Josh Hammer. All I see is Candace being like proven increasingly
incorrect on everything she's asserted. And she like doubles
down in different directions and says she didn't even like make
the claim that they're saying she made. And she she's just like
spinning around. She's like a
She's just like a top spinning around between points. She's I
didn't do that. I didn't do that. I didn't do that.
You two after 911 was my favorite. I think you too I've heard
is just always a good concert or it was back in the 2010s. Charlie
is an angel. came to Candace while she slept and told her that
Israel killed him.
I think I think Candace Owens just might not like Okay, I listen
I've tried to come up with other explanations for what Candace
Owens is doing. I think she just might not like people that might
that Now, I never make that criticism when people are criticizing
Israel. I never really make that criticism. Okay? I try to stick
away from that. I try to keep anti- Zionism and anti-semitism
very far apart. But with Candace, I feel like, hey, I might just
actually say, you know what? I think she just doesn't like those
people. Those guys, she don't like them. She's not a big fan.
J, remember when Apple forced that one YouTube album on everyone's
iPod? Yeah, I remember it. I remember it. We all remember it.
Okay. Okay. All right. All right. What are we doing next? Where
are we going? Oh, I want to go to the Yeah, the Chicago stuff.
All right. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Okay. I'm going to have to
go. We're going to start with this Joe Rogan clip. Okay. Basically,
I think what we're seeing increasingly, all
more and more,
is this idea that, oh, like I wanted deportations to happen,
but I wanted it to happen to criminals. I thought it was going
to happen to bad people. It seems like they're going into like
[__] grocery stores and grabbing whatever brown person
they can and then testing them and like trying to deport. It
seems like they're not really just going after criminals. They're
like they're going pretty hard. Wait, wait, I didn't want this.
And some big names like Theo Vaughn, like Joe Rogan, I feel like
they're starting to push back and go, "Whoa,
I didn't want this. I didn't I didn't want Trump for this. I
didn't want this." So, hold on. There's a recent Joe Rogan episode
on it. Okay, it's from two days ago. And this was big news. I
missed it somehow. I don't know how I missed it because a lot
of people a lot of people caught it, but this is like the big
one. Okay, Joe Rogan kind of just goes like quite hard on the
Trump administration,
at least at different points in this. So, I I grabbed there's
like shorter clips. There's like 10, 15, 20 second clips, but
I want to go watch the whole thing like basically from where
they start talking about this all the way through. So, let's
check it out. Back with the human rights compassion angle. His
take is, yeah, but
which which do we pick? which do we choose
creating some way for people to stay in the United States who
came here as kids and do the nuance compassionate thing but it
gives the impression to the rest of the world that we're doing
that and that gets
x amount of people
why is this guy dressed as a priest I have no idea I didn't go
to the beginning of the episode to find out both him and Joe
Rogan are I got no idea what's going on with that okay no >> that
that many people die that was his take on it which is why they're
doing >> They're still going to have human trafficking
and if you've got a very closed border and you give amnesty,
they're going to let they're going to figure out a way to get
people in. >> That was people going to die. >> That's
his argument. And and you know the what you when he was talking
about like all the awful he's seen and you hear it in his voice.
>> Ah, they always wear a costume together. Duncan and
Joe always wear a costume together. Okay, good to you're like,
"Okay, maybe I don't completely agree with your point of view,
but I can
where you're coming from there." And yet,
when you see this in practice, you know, when you when you It's
not an NPR, when you see the videos you've been seeing and everyone
else has been
>> okay, this is a big point, okay? When you don't hear
the like canned messaging from politicians, when you see how
it actually looks on the ground, holy,
this is bad. It's disturbing.
I think this is it's almost
it's very funny. Okay, it's very amusing to me because it mirrors
another situation where people were willing to look the other
way on really bad behavior from a certain government possibly
in the Middle East because they didn't see what the situation
on the ground was like dayto-day. And then, you know, people
started getting Tik Tok, people started getting, you know, phones
started being more ubiquitous in Gaza, and we started seeing
what it looks like dayto-day. And it's like, oh, there's no way
to sweep for this. There's literally no way to sweep for this
at all. And I think that effect is going to start happening
to the Trump administration and to ICE, to all of these DHS agents
who are going around the country, right? The optics are horrible.
And I think that's we're seeing this creep into like actual culture
already. Then you realize like there's okay, sure, but there
must be a a way to do this that doesn't involve ripping parents
out of their communities, away from their children. That doesn't
involve like actually removing people who've been contributing
to society to American society from American society. Sending
people to other countries when they can't even speak the language.
>> You know what I mean? So, >> no. There's no one
with a heart is going to go along with that. >> And no
one I did not >> I think Joe is underestimating what is
the bonus for ICE right now? It's like $30,000 $40,000.
There's like a massive bonus for signing up for ICE. Okay. I
I think he's he's he's very rich and so he doesn't understand
the concept of like people struggling with money. Um there are
a lot of people who are getting a lot of money to go to ICE.
It's like a $50,000 signing bonus. Yeah. the the signing bonus
for ICE to to join them. Like what it's up to is crazy. Yeah.
No, a lot of people I I I'm willing to bet guys that it's like
50,000 if you have like a ton of experience or something, but
it it is like I think it's reliably like 5 10 grand or something
to get people in, right? Like if you have like basically nothing
like you get good benefits, good uh like a signing bonus, you
get a reasonable salary
and a lot of people will sign up. That's not
>> I did not ever anticipate seeing that on TV on a regular
basis. >> Me either, man. Me either. It's shock. It's it
>> I really thought they were just going to go after the
criminals. I really thought there was enough gang members and
enough people MS-13 members and whatever they were looking for
that that that they're wanted. They would go after those guys.
I really I totally thought Listen, when he said when he said
that the criminals are poisoning the blood of our nation, I really
just thought he meant the criminals. I didn't realize he meant
the brown people, too. I didn't know that.
Is this just their Is this their confessional?
Uh, no. I think they just wear costumes for fun. It's just It's
so crazy how it's like a bunch of people were like screaming
about the civil rights abuses that would happen under a new Trump
administration. Project 2025, all of this stuff, right? And and
Joe's like, I just really He's saying the things out loud. He's
like, I just I just can't believe they like they're like doing
a mass deportation campaign. Joe, you realize they had like an
exact plan. Like they had they literally had precise logistical
layouts of how they're going to execute mass deportations in
major cities, right? You know that they went to the the pains
of doing all this, of laying it out for you, right? Oh no, man.
I had no idea, man. I had no idea they're going to do this, dude.
I didn't think it'd get this bad, man. I I You know, >> that's
what I thought, right? But how many gang members have they actually
>> No idea. No idea. But you you see how
you know,
dude, when they said they were going to like drone strike boats
from drug dealers, I thought they meant they were just going
to get drug dealers from like Venezuela. Man, I didn't know they're
going to get Colombians. And I hate using this word because the
word is getting thrown around so much.
>> Oh, don't do the f Don't do fascist. Don't do authoritarian.
Somebody might get shot. Okay, Christy Gnome might get shot at
if you say that this is authoritarian. Guys, don't say authoritarian.
Don't say fascist. That would be terrible. >> And it's
a stupid Well, you say that word. I'll say authoritarianism.
>> he was going to say Oh my god. He was going to say fascist
and he switched it to authoritarian.
He was gonna say it and he knew that he would get blown up by
all the people in this whole sphere and he rolled it back to
authoritarian.
>> Oh, cowardly.
>> You see how,
>> you know, and I hate using this word because the word
is getting thrown around so much and it's a stupid Well, you
say that word, I'll say
>> You see how how authoritarianism
when it begins to emerge, it's not like it's like non-consensual.
You see how it slowly slowly creeps in and how there's a great
many people >> directly impacted
by
um people who have u you crossed the border without using the
right protocol and
in a horrific way and and
there are
>> He's he's doing the Lake and Riley bit. He's given a
nod to Lake and Riley. >> Been in apartment complexes there.
So there's people who've seen those videos
>> And they're like,
"Yeah, fuck." And also a lot of people who got citizenship the
regular way, went through hell to get citizenship here, they're
also like, "Fuck them. They're cutting in line. These they're
gumming up the system. They're making it so that we who are following
how how much like I love that he's like trying to explain to
himself. And he's like, "No, you have to remember like Lake and
Riley and that apartment that got taken over by MS-13 and like
like there were really bad things happening. Like thousands were
dying. I only saw like two examples, but thousands were dying."
He's like trying to convince himself that he made good decision.
Well, actually, I don't know. He could have voted for uh Camala
for all I know. But like I feels like he's trying to convince
himself that this was something that wasn't to believe in the
first place. Just slowly over time he's like I I can convince
myself. Just remember I have to remember Lake and Riley. Beautiful
white girl. Beautiful young white girl. I don't want to I don't
want to go techone mode there. Okay, dude. Techone. You guys
remember Tee with that Ukrainian girl?
Beautiful young Ukrainian girl who's wearing all of her clothes.
Who's wearing all of her clothes? She wasn't even She wasn't
even like dressed provocatively >> following the rules.
Not only it's taking us longer, but also now we have to deal
with ICE, too. So those people are so there is a contingent of
people uh who maybe feel the same thing all of us are feeling
but also are like but
you
what's worse
you know I I like I'm you know this is how I think the the only
way to do it would be where you could get everyone on your side
borders are closed and we're going to find out who's committed
felonies
who out of the people that are illegal that have committed felonies
and if you've committed x amount of felonies, you have you have
to leave the country.
>> Right. If you've been robbing people for the last 10
years and you're an illegal, you have to leave the country, right?
That makes sense.
>> Hold on. Wait, doesn't he realize that like the argument
has he never talked to a Republican about this ever? You know
what they say back to this, right? Oh, well, illegal residency
is is illegal. like you are already you've already broken the
law. You're just by being here, you've broken the law, >> but
if you've been here for 25 years, you have a family, your kids
go to school here, you speak the language,
you're just illegal, but you're a contributing member to the
community that up until now has been protected. This is crazy
to ask lower income and and middle inome people who are, you
know, kind of getting by and then all of a sudden you're about
to ship them to a country where they've never been. They haven't
been since they were four. >> And you're going to you're
going to pull up their family and pull up and they've been in
the community like that >> that that shows no heart. And
that's the problem. Like you're not going to get any reasonable
people to want to go along with that. Any kind person would look
at that and go there's this can't be the only way to do this.
>> Damn right.
>> Wow. It's almost like It's almost like
Yeah. It's almost like that was everybody's concern was that
Republicans are not kind and thoughtful people. It's it was almost
like their concern that this Trump administration had shown a
lack of humanity that was very concerning given their rhetoric
around immigration and all the Project 2025 stuff, right? It's
almost like a bunch of people were concerned that they were going
to do this exact thing. Democrats are certainly far more than
Republicans. Yes, certainly.
I'm sorry. You only have one viable party in your country. Yes,
Democrats are infinitely more compassionate, probably too compassionate,
but the issue is the people on the other side have kind of lost
it in the other direction, right? But but you see once authoritarianism
starts creeping in and it makes some inroads, which it's definitely
making right now, man. It's definitely making right now. And
and you know, I think one thing both of us have in common is
really good at like thinking from the other perspective. Like
I can put myself fully into the mind of like a super paranoid
person who lives in a city that's all [__] up >> and
who's like Yeah. It's like remember that awesome show
where it's like one of those vengeance shows where that that
this dad waits
did the same deportations under Obama. Really?
I I don't even know if people are concerned as much. Listen,
the deportations are bad. This is really bad. I'm more laughing
at like the actual optics of like just beating white people on
the streets, right? Like I don't think anybody signed, not even
Republicans signed up for that. Okay, they're just going to tackle
a 50-year-old white woman on the street and beat the [__]
out of her. Well, tie her up and mush her face into the >> His
family gets up by gang members and then he just goes and starts
shooting people. You Charles Bronson. >> Oh, yeah. Death
wish. >> Death wish. Yeah. >> Right. So there's a
lot of people who are in death wish mode right now and they're
just like yeah get the troops in the streets these I get my car
broken into every night nothing's happening let's go and from
you know their perspective it all makes sense but the problem
is once we all start getting used to the military in the streets
>> and once we just accept it
>> that's no dude I am getting listen I am getting the
general idea of I'm seeing it, okay, in my head. Who's the comedian
who did the bit about how Joe Rogan is like Kubla Khan or Kenghask
Khan and he has like the the person in front of him just he has
the person in front of him who's like trying to do the pantoime
to convince Joe without saying Joe's right. He's like trying
to convince Joe of his point without making it clear that like
Joe knew all of this before and still voted and endorsed Trump,
right? He's like trying to slowly convince him like going he's
like circumnavigating Joe's ego to try to get Joe to change his
opinion. is very effective. This used to be Duncan's full-time
job. Oh, he's good at it, right? I could see how he's like, "Dude,
I can totally understand the other side, but like, man,
once you accept the military in the streets, I know you're like
a libertarian, right? They got the military in the streets, man."
And I don't know, like once you accept that, what what's the
next step, dude? What would it be? And Joe's like, "Yeah, yeah,
once you accept that, things would get really bad."
>> Good in the streets. I mean, once we just accept it.
>> That's no good. >> But it's like, >> how
bad does the police have to get at doing their job? Or is it
the upper management that institutes policies? Or is it that
the people vote these policies in? But whatever it is that allows
the kind of chaos that you could find in Portland, like whatever
this is, you guys aren't doing it right. If this was a >> bro,
I I need people to understand the difference between Portland
in 2020 and Portland now,
right? Like the difference in the violence and the directionality
of it is
It's nuts, dude.
>> What are you linking me? Like me and I came over your
house and these are your kids. I would call protective services,
right? I'd be like, "This psychopath must be smoking with his
kids cuz everybody's just running around camped out on the sidewalk."
Like, none of this makes I'd be like, "This this is an unfit
parent." That's an unfit government. If you've got a city where
people are just openly in the streets, sleeping everywhere, needles,
you have homeless tent. You ever see Oakland? You see some of
those homeless tents? >> Yeah, dude. >> Those huge
villages. Like, this is bananas.
This didn't exist when we were >> Well, dude, this is the
thing. Like I actually when I was living in LA.
>> Okay, hold on. Riyle says the latest elephant graveyard
video accused Duncan of slacking because this was his job. Apparently,
his job was to
wrangle Joe Rogan. That was that was who Duncan Trussell's always
been. He's Joe Rogan's wrangler. You sell, >> take this
guy, Duncan Trussell, for example, one of Joe's longtime friends
and a former advocate of radical honesty, truth seeeking, and
psychedelic wisdom. Not long ago, he was the lone voice of reason
in Joe's inner circle, and the only guy to openly predict how
Joe would be corrupted by powerful forces looking to exploit
him for access to his farreach.
Yeah, people have decided you're one of the magnifying glasses
focusing this beam of >> Yeah, I think we've watched this
precisely. So, apparently, yeah, basically this guy called out
by Elephant Graveyard. Maybe maybe somebody passed the word along
that like, hey, you looked in on how how Joe's doing recently.
Oh, hold on. >> Oh my god, >> we've got we've got
Asthma slop on the same topic after Oh my worlds are
>> Let's go. We've got asthma slop after this.
Oh, very cool.
Hold on. Let's get back >> I was like thinking of like
what are some fun ways to like
[__] disturb. I was thinking, you know what you could
do?
You could throw a music festival, but you could tell everyone
who comes to the music festival to pretend to be homeless. Bring
tents, put the tents out. They can't do [__] But
if you threw a music festival in LA and didn't get any licensing
like >> Oh, this is not a good point. >> You can
camp out. It's going to be awesome. Everybody's going to jail.
You know what I mean?
>> Yeah. He understands the difference, right? The reason
the reason the homeless people get left alone is cuz they have
nothing. Like literally jailing them would cost you money. And
and like it's not even I don't know. It's probably not even correct
to do. But like there's just nothing. There's no law or way to
get rid of them that
they have nothing to lose is the point, right? They have nothing
to lose at all.
And so you can't take anything from them. If you're throwing
a music festival, they've got like equipment they can seize from
you. They've got tons of [__] they can seize from
you, right? There's just nothing to lose on the on the homeless
guys. What did the fox guy say? I think he said them, which is
really gross. Okay, you can do a burning man. just like guys
we're just if they ask this we're we're homeless and you you'll
be fine. And it's that
that's that's the place where it gets where this is the problem
is it's like
>> this is what
>> uh Shogim Trump called idiot compassion. There's compassion
then there's idiot compassion. Now, idiot compassion is thinking
that leaving a a bunch of people out in the streets who have
are in varying degrees of psychosis and drug addiction and long-term
brain injury
and then thinking it's let's just let them do their thing when
they obviously need help. If they were young, if those were 11
year olds, go back to the kid idea. If those were like eight-year-olds,
people would be helping them because >> because they're
full grown. No more >> dude. I was I was I'm sorry. >> I
was just going to tell you. >> Yeah, we have a lot more
compassion for people who haven't like [__] up in
some way. >> I'm sorry. >> Regardless of what you
think about it.
>> Ah, no. Come on, man. You make so much >> They
have different policies. It is squeaky clean >> and the
guys are in the >> Okay, hold on. There's one more point
to this. So, we've we've watched through this whole thing. We've
watched through at least the the part we were going to watch
through. Now, the backlash against Joe Rogan over this clip has
been massive everywhere online. Like tons of people doing the
exact same [__] they did to like Kyle Writtenhouse,
right? Like, oh, Joe's Joe's going to step outside of this orthodoxy.
Yeah, we're coming for your head now. We're coming for your head.
Right. So, I think that's where Asminold's going to go with this
is he's probably seen some of the tweets like this, right? Like
here, have a [__] heart Joe Rogan to real Donald
Trump. [__] this worthless, unfunny, cowardly [__]
and every other [__] who thinks he's clever or worth
listening to. You don't get to play the liberal after you helped
elect that pedto. You own everything he does. Oh, this is somebody
who's this is somebody who wants to make it like a buzzsaw for
people who want to admit they're wrong and try to like uh fix.
Bro, this is not the way, dude. This is not the way. When people
do good things, you go, "That's good. Do the sandwich." Okay,
that's good. I really like hearing this good opinion. Now, I
don't think this undoes some of the bad he's said, some of like
the his culpability in electing Trump, but he's going the right
direction, and I'll support him if he does start going in the
right direction. Right? That's you just do the sandwich. You
don't you don't like let him off the hook, quote unquote, but
why the don't make coming back to your side a buzzsaw for anybody
who wants to do it. Okay, you're going to trap them over there.
SK Media has barely left. I don't know who that is. He's just
pro Ukraine guy. I don't know. >> The immigration thing,
the way it looks is horrific. When you're just arresting people
in front of their kids and just normal regular people that have
been here for 20 years, >> that everybody who has a heart
>> can't get along with that. >> I guess I don't
have a heart. >> I'm totally okay with it. I think they
should do a
>> Oh, I don't know what I thought. I don't know what I
thought he was going to say. I kind of thought he'd go in the
same direction,
right? I really did think he'd go in the same direction. Holy
[__] I'd expect Well, there you go. There's Joe's
There's
There's If Joe wanted to put his finger on the pulse, okay, he's
like, "Oh, man. I just don't think that seems like really inhuman,
man. That seems like really up."
And as just like, "Yes, I am antisocial. Yes, I don't have any
social connections. Yes, my parents were the last people I talked
to in real life essentially ever. And I've now that I've severed
all connections to this mortal coil, I will start having the
inh I'll just start projecting total inhumity to all of my viewers.
Cool. Great. That's awesome, man. That's so awesome.
Here, I'm going to hit play. By the way, this video is like 10
minutes old, but uh I'm going to hit play on this. I'm going
to use the bathroom really quickly. I'm doing a like a Hassan
chair react really quickly. All right, let's uh let's go.
I'll be right back. more.
Just because you have your kids with you doesn't mean that you're
immune to
It's emotional manipulation.
>> everybody who has a heart sees that and goes, "That
can't be right. That can't be right. That can't be the only way
to do this."
>> well, the other way to do it would be to have closed
the borders ahead of time, and that way it would have never been
an
Anytime that somebody gets apprehended by the police for committing
a crime or doing something wrong, they're separated from their
family or from their kids. If they're at if they're with their
kids, it's not like this is some kind of get out of jail free
card. You still go to
It doesn't even make sense. This is like it's totally illogical
in every other application of this rule. >> You have to
think, look, yeah, we have to have a border. Yes, it should have
been secure. Yes, they should make sure you know who everybody
is before they get in. >> But when people been here for
20 years, like come on, man. That's crazy. Like, >> I agree.
It is crazy. >> How are you here for 20 years?
You break the law for 20 years, you can't figure out how to get
a visa. You can't go through the immigration process. You can't
do anything. >> Dude, I wish I could have been here. I
wish I could have been here to like do a soundboard. When he
said exactly what I told Joe, okay, we watched the Joe clip.
I said, "You don't understand, Joe. They're just going to say
you you entered the country. You broke the law by entering the
country. It's over for you." Yes, there are a lot of people who
can just dehumanize swaths of other people. I would love to watch
Asmin Gold. I listen, I just want Asmin Gold to put this to the
test. Are you really that heartless? Cuz I think he's actually
fronting right here. Okay, Asmin Gold, go ahead. pull up a video
clip of some father being pulled away from their listen guy like
owns a store but he's actually here illegally 20 years ago 25
years ago right and he gets pulled away from his family and deported
he's got like young kids or something I want you to open that
video up watch it and go yeah that's what you deserve yeah your
kid crying that's all that's all your fault you deserve to leave
I know that you're a taxpaying citizen you're a massive benefit
to this country but you you entered illegally 20 years ago I
don't believe it I literally don't believe it's comic comical
evil. It's It's actually just comical evil,
right? There's just no way.
But I just think he's fronting right now 100%. Uh there's one
other thing he said here.
Asmin sees immigrants as less than Ka Hassan shocked his his
dog permanently ban him from this platform. Oh, that that person's
like their kids are crying as they have their parents ripped
away. Well, shouldn't have entered the country illegally 20 years
ago, man. Shouldn't have done it. Shouldn't shouldn't have done
that. Has
he does he has he heard of a statute of
I don't know. Dogs are better than us. It's
Vosch already told you they were they are irredeemably evil.
Yeah, that's true. Vos pondered the orb. I should never doubt
Vos, but I'm going to do it for a little bit. Okay. I don't I
don't think Listen, I think Joe is more representative of the
average person. Asmin Gold is representative of somebody who
who absorbs like a ton of feedback and criticism and has scorn
for it, right? I think with Joe, I think Joe just like doesn't
listen to a ton of the criticism. I don't think he gets pushed
by criticism in the same way that like a lot of other influencers
do. He probably does. I'm saying he I don't think he looks. There's
no statute of limitations on entering illegally. There isn't,
but I'm telling you there should be. That that is basically what
I would expect an amnesty to be. that if you've lived in the
country peacefully, taxpayingly, productively for like x number
of years, well, you should get amnesty. They should make you
a citizen. Hey, I don't know what I don't know what circumstances
you came here under, but you could be a citizen because you've
met like certain criteria. Seems to be totally reasonable to
me, but I don't know. That's I don't know how that could possibly
not be obvious to people, but we'll continue. How does that make
any
How is it that these people can disrespect the laws?
Why would anyone come legally if you could just stay for a while
and be let in? Because you don't have a risk of getting deported
and missing the next amnesty and living in fear for the next
like 15 or 20 years. So everybody who could come in legally would
still just come in legally. Some people might come in illegally
hoping for another amnesty, but they're living under in like
total fear for a long period of time. It's not like, oh, setting
doing an amnesty, you know, once every 20, 30 years is going
to set a precedent that like, oh, if you could hide from ICE
for 30 years, you'll be safe.
Like that seems like very few people are going to choose that
I would assume,
right? Anybody who's not in like dire straits wouldn't choose
that. And the people who are dire straits aren't going to care
if they get amnesty or not. They're just going to keep coming
back,
Like anybody who is coming here because they had no option to
live in their country that they thought they were totally hopeless
in their own country. Those people are still going to come to
the United States regardless of whether there's an amnesty or
not. >> And also a lot of these people are doing identity
theft. They're doing other They're paying some taxes. They're
not paying other taxes. Uh I wonder like Yeah, steal an American's
job in a lot of cases. Yes. And
it's just insane. So yeah, I don't know what to say.
So I think there's a problem for for like the there's a blue
collar labor gap that illegals fill. That's like a problem, but
it's like at such a scale I don't know how you fix it, right?
Like basically economics are such that the illegals are like
structurally required in a lot of cases, right? You you'd have
to like reorient the economy significantly somehow to make up
for actually this is what you saw with all of the uh what was
it? All of the exceptions to
there's like exceptions for illegal I guess hires in the Midwest,
right? For farmers for farming jobs. They basically couldn't
do the farming jobs. like they're economically not viable without
illegal immigrant participation, which sucks, but I don't know
if that means you go actually uh we we shut this all down now.
I don't think that's I don't think that's possible. So, like
I think there are jobs that nobody else will do and probably
those jobs are predicated on illegals working really long hours
for very low pay.
But I don't know if like shutting down certain farming industries
is viable right now. That's which is why I assume Trump did all
of his exceptions to a lot of these deportations for people who
were farmers. So you want slaves? I don't want slaves. But the
American economy is going to like actually go topsyturvy if you
just kick all the slaves out at once. Okay? I'm invoking the
South's argument before before the Civil War.
Listen, we can't we can't just give all these people up. What
the [__] going to happen? You don't understand.
You don't understand, man.
But like probably you need some progressive
releasing of this over time, right? I think I think what they
should do is is eventually just get to the point where they enforce
a minimum wage for illegal immigrants.
Yeah. Anyway, it's crazy, man. Thank you. I've been saying this
for years. Yeah, exactly. So, I don't I I think that this argument
works, but it works in the opposite direction. How is it that
these people have been here for 20 years, but they couldn't figure
out how to get any form of citizenship or residence in the country?
Like, what are you doing? Let's find a way if they've been product.
>> These people I I assume like
I just want him to think about it, right?
Yeah. Like he should just think about that. That that should
prompt maybe I think this is like the key to having a not as
as successful stream as gold. Okay. Because I think I do this
and I think it can be boring for some people, but I think it's
important to do, right? You should actually go and when you ask
a question like that, you should try to think of the answer.
Why wouldn't somebody go and report themselves or go and try
to sign up for some kind of citizenship after they'd been there
for a while, right? Why wouldn't they do that? It's like you
would open up I'd open up perplexity. I'd start looking like,
hey, if I'm in America as an illegal citizen, what would happen
to me? Thinking equals anti-success. Yeah, you just do your reactionary
takes. You make it as entertaining as possible. But like I think
that would be helpful to him to just think through these things
sometimes, right? Yeah. It's like well I don't know that there's
a mechanism for him. Does that mechanism exist that he could
like leave and come back without losing everything? He just has
to go back to the place that he fled that he was willing to risk
life and limb to to flee. I don't know. >> Active members
of society for 20 years. No criminal record. They worked the
entire time. They paid taxes.
>> Find them a pathway to citizenship. Find a way where
you can do this. >> Because if you do that, then you provide
a reward structure around people breaking the law.
>> If you ever
Okay, no such reward structure exists now. They're still breaking
the law. So like this is where you have to figure out what your
actual argument is, right? because no part of a pathway to citizenship
or incentivizing um people who have been productive for a long
period of time by giving them an amnesty, no part of that incentivizes
criminal behavior, right?
But they will constantly hit you over the head with the criminal,
okay, illegal immigrant crime, illegal immigrant crime. They'll
hit you over the head with that. Like that is the biggest problem.
But then you give them a solution that doesn't actually with
that problem at all,
that that like it still makes it a huge problem. It doesn't it
doesn't reward any of those people
and they still do this. They still do this. No, it's it's ultimately
coming down to like they took our jobs, which I understand. I'm
sympathetic to like your labor pool, your low-skll labor pool
being eaten up by people who are from outside of your country.
I'm sympathetic, but you have to understand that there are ways
to end that problem slowly over time that are going to be far
better for your country than just like just kicking all these
people out instantly.
I don't know. Also, there's the whole, you know, humanity thing,
the whole humanity aspect, which Asmin Gold's missing out on.
>> Have a system that rewards people for breaking the law.
You've created a system that rewards people for breaking the
law.
Why is it that a person who intentionally disrespects and breaks
the law of a country gets to get moved to the front of the immigration
pattern or sorry, the immigration line and get made a citizen
or a resident of the country?
How is it fair to everybody else who didn't break the law that
the people that did get first first chances over
How is it fair to them? It's like not fair to them, but ultimately,
here's the thing. We're talking about decisions you make on a
scale that affect the entire economy of the country, right? And
ultimately it's like we need to actually fix a problem, illegal
immigration, okay, that has a multitude of like negative effects
that people see or you know maybe aren't necessarily negative
but have negative effects on certain people. Okay, you want to
address that in a way that doesn't destroy the economy, doesn't
cause like additional suffering. And some of that's going to
include keeping some of those illegal immigrants. You can't just
if you want to morally act like, okay, we have to kick everybody
out who's ever come here illegally because like they broke the
law and it's really unfair to the people who tried to come here
legally. If you want to follow that through and stick staunchly
to that principle, that is going to cause major major problems
in the United States. Are you willing to stomach those problems?
Do you have any idea what those problems are? Have you thought
about it at all? Right? Have you thought of the economic upheaval
that will happen if you do these things? And ultimately, I'm
pretty sure that answer is no. Right. Ultimately, pretty sure
that answer is no, because I don't think Trump thought about
it either. And he had to scramble to like actually, oh, actually,
farmers come back. Farmers, farmers, come back, come back, come
back, come back. We We need crops. We need food. We need to not
like totally we we need to not make grocery prices more expensive.
Whoops.
This is and and I think this is the problem that a lot of people
have is that they always think about things from a very very
limited perspective and they never think about it with other
people and how they're being treated. Well, then why not change
the law? So true. >> Well, because I agree with the law.
I think that you shouldn't just randomly let people in the country.
I agree with it. I think that's the way the rules should be and
I don't see any I I I see no logical reason.
Guys, what's the joke goes? Man, I don't know how you could like
It seems like inhuman. It seems like so bad. You watch this this
child ripped away from their parent who's getting deported. How
could you? And Asmin Gold's like, "What's wrong with that? Of
course I like that. Of course, that's fine. Yeah, what's wrong
with that? What's wrong with that?" And then he's like, "Okay,
I have a I have the ability to think of things from other people's
perspective." Actually, if you guys I have a little skill called
called empathy.
Okay, good one, man. >> And otherwise,
>> yeah, yeah, a point. Exactly. I've been waiting a turn.
Yeah, of course. Right. So, if I rob banks for 20 years and I
get caught on my 21st year, I shouldn't get in trouble. Yeah.
It It's just
>> That's literally no part of an amnesty would would give
amnesty to somebody who's a bank robber. It's amnesty for a
>> about this makes sense at all. >> And I think
that really this is what's happened. I think this is what's very
clearly happened is that people like Joe Rogan, Theo Vaughn,
a couple of these other podcasters,
they
are afraid of the negative optics of, you know, arresting people
in front of their kids or something. >> Oh, okay. He gets
that. Yes, he does understand that. Okay, so this is like this
is interesting cuz this will break Asminold away from a lot of
the other people around him, a lot of his fan base, I think.
I think he's got some fans who are humans. They're a couple,
right?
And it's very interesting. Okay. Kind of points back at my whole
thought into
him being more intelligent than he might let on that like a lot
of is very
because
this sounds like true believer in a way that I wouldn't have
expected from him. And
man, I don't know.
I just think it's very interesting. And I think broadly my belief
is most human beings, okay, are social animals that will want
to do like that will want to not do harm, that will feel some
kind of like pain in their soul at the idea of separating families.
I think that's proven been proven out multiple times, right?
This is the same thing politicians run all the time in terms
of polling and stuff. That is the thing that gets people right.
the idea of splitting up families of with this this family unit
and I think
I think the Republicans are totally up with all of their ice
plays right now. I think it's totally something like that and
they don't want to be seen as that kind of a person. But really
it's not about the optics. anybody. If you're ever worried about
the optics of something, you've now become manipulated by a person
who wants to take advantage of you because you've effectively
given your ability to decide your own fate away to somebody else
who often times doesn't want you to succeed. So really, whenever
you're caring about how do how do people how will people who
don't like me perceive what I'm doing? Well, they're going to
try to make it look wrong. They're going to try to make it look
bad. That's the real reason.
>> Okay, but I think the Okay, lucky for us. All right,
this is a very easy way to look at this. When you see the Tik
Tok clips and stuff, you just get to see the footage, right?
It is I'm telling you, he is describing
he is trying to be Israel explaining why in context that child
that you see in five different pieces on the screen, that's actually
them being humane. That's what Asminold's trying to do right
now, right? That child that you see in multiple pieces on the
ground, that's actually the most the most moral army on earth
at work. Okay? And it's like, bro, I'm sorry. You can't make
people believe that. People will always, always, always understand
something from a clip like that empathetically and they will
feel something. And I have to believe this or I would probably
just not want to be a person on Earth right now, okay? is why
I think sentiment has shifted so drastically on Israel and I
think the same thing is going to happen with regards to the ICE
raids within American cities, right? Going and having this military
presence. I don't think they think it looks cool. They think
it's going to look badass. And maybe to a certain certain type
of like ma boomer, it looks cool, but those people are not as
numerous as some people think. Okay, there's not as many of those
people as you think.
>> They aren't afraid of optics. They're afraid of Democrats.
I I mean, I'm sure some of them are, but like I mean, I think
there's more than that, too.
You're making this argument. Well, you admitted multiple times.
You didn't play credit card loans multiple times. Yeah. Well,
I No, that was my mom to be fair. That was my mom and she did
get away with it. Yeah, you're right. But like what I'm saying
is that
and also I think credit card companies are total scams to begin
with. They're scammers and so them
uh hold on. So Kringle Kesh says Israel wouldn't say that is
good, but rather that caused that. Yeah, that's a part of the
argument. It's the most moral army on earth that like the caused
the war and like is the person who puts those citizens in harm's
way. Sure. Same as what I'm saying earlier. People will believe
it's the people erroneously claiming asylum or illegally crossing
that are doing the damage to their own families through their
own actions and we are simply enforcing our laws. People don't
believe that. Okay? You could say that, but I'm telling you it
doesn't work for Israel because you can see that child's charred
corpse. Okay? And that elicits a a response from people that
you can't sweep away.
And I'm saying that the the presence of these people in American
cities right now is eliciting a response from people that can't
be swept away. You can't just go, "Well, actually, illegal immigrants
are really a problem." And look at like people are losing jobs.
It's like at some point at some point you're not going to win
that, okay? You you aren't you're not going to win.
At least that's my opinion. I don't think that it's a scam that
you can't come into the United States unless you fill out paperwork.
And so, yeah, it's a little bit
And uh gosh, I mean, yeah, there are no hiding places around
here. Nowhere I know. Yeah, of course. And and so that's the
really the difference to me. But either way, I mean, you're trying
to make this like a personal thing for me or whatever. You're
Why are you attacking me? Shouldn't you be attacking what I'm
saying rather than trying to draw this like just completely dishonest
comparison that doesn't have anything to do with what I'm saying?
Like wh why are you even Why are you even bringing up? So, he's
saying, um, well, I actually didn't hear the comment he's responding
to, but like it's probably going to be something calling him
inhuman. And for me, I'm sitting here and he's like, "Oh, why
won't you engage with my argument?" Well, your argument is that
no matter what, you should have to uphold the laws, right? That
it's unfair to other people. And I think you probably don't stay
consistent on that, right?
His mom never paid credit card bills or something.
Oh,
hypocrisy argument. I like I think you could just say that this
argument doesn't work. At least it depends on what you're trying
to do, right? That's basically what it depends on. So his argument
is, oh well, just because there's a crying child there and they're
using my emotions, doesn't mean like this is categorically incorrect.
And that could be something that you believe, but I think most
people have a belief that like if someone's living in your country
for a long period of time, they're peaceful, they're productive,
that you shouldn't like go and separate their family, right?
I think a lot of people's dis dislike of illegal immigration
like this is it that it is used to propel forward human trafficking,
um like the drug cartels, drug trafficking, right? That's most
people's problem with illegal immigration. There's there is a
problem of the job stuff, but the job stuff is only a problem
for like so far as automation hasn't taken hasn't filled in that
gap yet, right? You get rid of the illegal immigrants. You have
the the automation step kicks in like right, they'll just start
paying to automate a whole bunch of different jobs that they
don't do now because they have below like I I guess subminimum
wage wages for
Aspen says he doesn't care if you got away with it for 20 years.
If you get caught 21 years later, good. That's the hypocrite
thing. Um well yeah somebody I think somebody one of his chatters
did the bank robbery like I robbed banks for 20 years and then
on the 21st year I get caught. It's like well the the crime isn't
the crime here. You can't do that because robbing a bank is not
like a sorry living there illegally is not like an active process
or something you're doing like you cross in illegally and then
you start living a life and at some point you stop thinking about
the fact that you crossed in illegally. Right. Hold on. Reality
needs to be based in culture. How are women treated? Have you
ever fed yourselves and or do you live off of welfare? What is
the value of a culture inside or outside of the west? Oh god.
Oh god. It's like a
Okay, hold on. We are not required by Look at this guy from Twitch
chat. We are not required by morality to reward the most backwards
and violent corners of the human experience.
Okay. Is this about Gaza? I can't even tell with this guy. Is
this about Gaza or is this about Asmin Gold? Because we're arguing
that peaceful contributing
uh illegal immigrants who have been there for like a decade or
something and have like have have like actually pay taxes, actually
productive members of society, that you should probably grant
them an amnesty,
right? That those people should probably not be getting deported
by ICE. Those should not be your focus. Your focus should be
criminals, gangs, all this, right? So, it doesn't sound like
you disagree with me. Thank you. You you actually don't disagree
with me at all. Thank you. Okay. It's all about humanity. Agreed.
up in the first place.
>> So this is not a principled stance. Uh no, not really.
I mean, well, my principles, so this is the way that I look at
it. Um I don't derive my morality or ethics from the law. I think
that to a certain extent, you have to follow the law, but my
morality and what I think is right and wrong doesn't really have
to do with the law. So there are a lot of things that I think
are okay that illegally are not okay and vice versa. So there
are some laws that I agree with and other laws that I don't agree
with. And the ones that I do agree with, I think that we should
enforce and the other ones I don't think that we should enforce
that much. So it's really just that simple. And I the only difference
between I think me and a lot of other people is that I'm pretty
um I'm pretty open about this. I'm pretty open about this and
I think that this is a more honest conversation to have. But
I I mean, if you just want to say everybody's going to be selfish
and that's the way you see it, then that's fine. That's fine.
Then then you can't be mad. Asmin cannot possibly be mad. If
he wants to make this argument, oh, like people are selfish and
I'm going to be selfish. Then you can't be mad at people voting
for like free trade agreements, stuff that hollows out manufacturing,
stuff that sacrifices the productive like the uh occupations
of one state for the benefit of another. You can't be angry about
that. People are selfish. They'll vote for what helps them, right?
I think probably you should vote for what's best for your country.
Hold on, hold on, hold on. Oh, we have a new Oh, no. Hold on.
This is the old Kilargo Garcia video. This still shocks me. The
admin's vile. Okay, hold on. We'll watch it. illegal alien deportation
flight. Okay, I think this was the Kilbargo Garcia right off
the bat.
Oh, this is not even that dude.
ASMR. It's like there. Oh, this is actually significantly more
disgusting. Yeah, ASMR. Like the the Oh, we're shackling this
guy. Listen to his feet as he goes up the stairs with the shackle
sod.
Oh my god. ASMR. ASMR.
Awesome. Uh, Marilyn Plug Thug, can I ask your race really quickly?
I just I would be curious to know.
I just Listen, it's it's probably not relevant, but it might
be relevant.
Could you're white? I don't know about that. You should hop in
the Discord right now, okay? You should hop in the Discord. You
should You should definitely do that. Anyway, uh, where are we
at? We're looking at the Asenold video. Let's keep watching.
I don't think people want to have honest conversations. I think
that they want to hold on to optics and try to, you know, create
these weird little gotchas and stuff like that. That's it. So,
it's okay to not care about illegal. >> He can join Discord.
Yeah, you can join Discord if you want. Corwinch.
>> Uh, discord.gg/jstlk.
>> Immigrant law. No, I I agree with you, but I I I think
that's a stupid
So, and and I'm I'm going to pull up your your message here.
Um, give me give me one second. I I'll pull it up and I'll I'll
I'll respond to it. >> Oh [__] Asmin Gold going
in on a chatter. Let's go. >> Do you think that we should
let illegal aliens into the country
>> uh with without checking who they are?
>> No. Not my belief. >> Do you think we should do
that?
>> Do you think that that that's that's a good it's a good
decision for the country? And then you're just >> uh this
is actually not true. Color. I've literally posted my arm with
a sunburn on it. My extremely bleached white arm with this with
a sunburn. >> Wasting my time. You're wasting my time with
an argument that you don't even
You don't even think
>> Hold on. He How does he not understand that you could
say that people who even though I think you shouldn't do that?
Wait, wait, wait. Is he going to argue that there's a better
demonstration of who somebody is than them leaving living peacefully
and uh prosperously in your country doing the the work of actually
contributing to your country for years that you could figure
something out from their identity at the border through some
paperwork that says more about them than years than a decade
or more of living in your country as a prosperous like productive
citizen. I think that's insane. That's a totally ludicrous argument.
Jesus. >> Think this.
You're just you're just arguing for no reason.
Like I It's just What are you doing? Anyway, let's go ahead.
We'll move on. Right. They could have worked towards citizenship.
Yeah. It's just it's such a waste of time.
That was fast. Well, yeah. I mean, like I I I have no problem
with somebody that wants to like debate on something or whatever.
There is no argument. Every every country has borders. Yeah.
Exactly. thing that you want to do, which is keep terrorists
and cartel members from getting across the border with
drugs that kill 100 thousand people a year.
>> Yeah. I just like that's that'll be why he doesn't want
and you can do this if you you don't really argue with people
very much. Like you can do this, you can make that guy seem wrong,
but I don't think he has an actual argument for why that guy's
wrong unless he has a response to what I said. >> Okay.
but also have a heart because if you don't you're not going >> the
thing is with this is that there are a lot of a lot of it is
human trafficking as well and tremendous amounts of human trafficking
happen and because you're allowing people that are
China has negative immigration is
I think China is racing against the clock maybe they maybe they
make it to a point where they're like totally automated I just
think without chip technology they're I think they need to get
like really sophisticated automation going there before before
like their entire workforce drops dead of old age and they're
like racing against the clock super hard >> here to have
a path to >> oh did I miss I might have missed >> human
trafficking is >> well the thing is point I was making
a >> but also have a heart >> because if you don't
you're not >> well the thing is with this is that there
are a lot of a lot of it is human trafficking as well and tremendous
amounts of human trafficking happen and because you're allowing
people that are already here to have a path to citizenship if
they're found to be here. Then you've also created another reward
structure through a second order effect of human trafficking.
Because now if somebody who is already in the United States is
able to get a fasttracked path to citizenship, that makes it
all the more important to find somebody that will traffic you
into the United States.
Wait, wouldn't it just be I feel like you would just say Wouldn't
you just say like, "Oh, the the amnesty is only for people who
have been here a certain number a certain amount of time and
like other people could check in. They could recheck in at the
border, but if we have no record of you and you're not in this
amnesty period, you have to like go back and forth or something.
Wouldn't that be like you just figure out some of the numbers
and you try to make it as non-disruptive to the economy, I think,
as possible?"
And and this is the problem I think with a lot of this logic
here is that
>> it's not logic. It's just emotion. It's a emotional
reaction. B. >> Yeah. But this is, by the way, maybe this
makes sense for Asminold cuz Asminold does argue. Okay. He does
argue that most people shouldn't be voting. We just watched him
argue that, right? Most people shouldn't be voting.
Most people don't vote for good reasons. So he's like, "Oh, well,
it's all emotion, guys. It's all emotion." I'm my argument is
oh these emotions this emotional reaction this visceral reaction
is probably going to lead to some really bad polling some really
bad results for the Trump administration
and he's he's sort of confirming that to me
I guess by his by his like embrace of the administration position
he's sort of confirming to me like exactly what I think right
well and the coupled with the fact that he thinks fewer people
should be voting based off of something that you see rather than
thinking out what the right thing is and the best thing is for
the most people.
And I think that it's very easy for somebody to see a YouTube
video or somebody to see a clip that's upsetting or emotionally
touching to them and then decide that actually, you know what,
let's just get rid of this rule. But there's always a lot of
times secondary effects and sometimes other direct effects that
are just not considered with why these rules exist in the first
place.
Now, I think that's one of the big problems. Okay, wait.
I'm going back and forth between reading chats because there's
just a lot of people chatting right now. Did I miss what rule
he's talking about specifically or is he talking like hypothetically
about rules around immigration or emotionally
touching to them and then decide that actually you know what
let's just get rid of this rule. But there's always a lot of
times secondary effects and sometimes other direct effects that
are just not considered with why these rules exist in the first
place.
>> Wait. Yeah, sure. But he understands that a part of
that would be like um like unwritten rules as well, right? Why
do you think despite illegal immigration being illegal? Why do
you think you have so many people who are occupied sorry uh who
have occupations who have jobs as illegal immigrants?
Right? Like you have to look at the other side of that. There's
a significant change happening is in they are starting to try
to deport a large number of illegal immigrants, right? Why has
nobody done that before? Why what are the downsides? what what
negative knock-on effects of this of this new policy are going
to exist? What positive effects of the old policy are things
that you're not thinking about? Like the same argument goes back
to him >> No, I think that's one of the big >> Get
anybody on your side. If you're doing this stuff publicly, throwing
women to the ground, handcuffing people just for >> existing
on the wrong side of the dirt. Not a criminal, not The only crime
they ever committed was coming over here as a >> They probably
didn't even know what the was going on. Yeah. Yeah. >> You
know, a lot of kids got snuck across when they were already born
in Mexico. >> Yeah. And that's the reason. >> All right.
Lot of I'm actually going to back it up a little bit because
I want to read this Marty comment here. Uh a more acute result
of deportations that signals initial impact. Not the real economy
was uh not the real economy was an unexpected $4 billion plus
default in a leveraged loan issued by First Brands, a company
whose consumer base primarily consisted of illegal immigrants
sent lots of volatility across credit. Over time, we will see
more of those events. Sure, I would say those people are probably
tracked less well, right? It's full of typos. I get what you're
saying that like a a company who had a lot of products who were
purchased by illegal immigrants, that company is defaulting on
their credit. They're obviously not a able to cover their their
debts and that's a probably a result of illegal immigrants being
sent out of the country, right? Well, deportations and maybe
even fear of deportations.
So, like it's causing economic ripple effects already or you
you think there's a good reason to believe there's signals that's
causing economic ripple effects
>> I'll go back. >> Get anybody on your side. If
you're doing this stuff publicly, throwing women to the ground,
handcuffing people just for >> existing on the wrong side
of the dirt. >> Not a criminal. Not The only crime they
ever committed was coming over here as a >> They probably
didn't even know what the was going on. >> Yeah. Yeah.
You know, a lot of kids got snuck across when they were
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> already born in Mexico. >> Yeah.
And that's the reason why you can't let them be kid. That's the
reason why you can't give them citizenship because if you do,
you've just created a reward structure across around sneaking
kids wait
>> across the border.
>> That's the exact reason why you can't do
Now you you have just created an incentive to do this.
Um, I find out I find out that 10 years ago somebody jumped into
a river to save a drowning kid. I'm like a billionaire philanthropist.
I give that guy a like $500,000 reward for something he did in
the past. I I don't have like any plans to do it ever again.
Have I created like a reward structure for people risking their
lives to help other people? I just feel like if it's if it's
explicitly a one-time event, I don't know. Like maybe you you
in the eyes of some people create like a reward structure, but
it doesn't seem like that like you make it clear it's not a matter
of policy. I don't know. It's like are you going to on the 0001%
chance you get like is it are you playing the lottery essentially
with your life then bunch of people who can't even swim are going
to jump into rivers to try to save kids?
I it just doesn't like it doesn't seem like it's a discernable
like trackable reward structure in any way.
>> Growing up their entire life in America, they can't
even speak Spanish.
Yeah, this era of feeling is upon us. Yeah, it's a it's an emotion.
Uh, are you happy with immigration levels in Canada? No, not
particularly.
No, I think I think Canada was making big mistakes with immigration.
I think we were doing legal immigration though. We don't have
like an illegal immigration problem in Canada, right? It's like
a totally different thing that the government was like fairly
open about like, hey, we're bringing all these people in. It's
trying to solve a different problem in terms of like our population
uh cliff, right?
But it I think it was causing lots of structural problems.
Mostly I was concerned it was going to cause like a literal race
war in my country. I want less immigration. I want I wanted them
to to tamp down on immigration because we were bringing in specifically
one nationality of immigrants at a massive scale. And it was
causing a lot of disruptions in terms of the housing market,
in terms of the employment market, right? Like we're bringing
in like 5% of our population
a year,
right? Like we're bringing in massive numbers of people, like
an insane number of people. Yeah. I think they've I think they
largely cut that down at this point. And like when when you're
creating structural problems in your country and it's all attributable
to one race, like that's going to cause really bad things to
happen that I don't want to have happen. Okay? I I trust you
all understand what I'm saying. Okay?
I And I don't I don't hate Indian people for coming here. I don't
hate anybody who's like reaching out to another place trying
to go to a different country for a better life. I don't hate
those people. I dislike the government that allowed like this
precise um this precise like system to be in place for as long
that it caused these kinds of structural issues. But I don't
begrudge any Indian people who came here on like some kind of
uh some kind of student visa or something tried to get here as
best they could. Okay, now we're all in the boat together. All
right, and the boat's still sinking. So, we all got to work hard
to pull our weight, pay our taxes, and
listen, we're in the strong men. Okay, we got to create good
times. >> Emotional argument and >> strong men phase.
>> Too much empathy means the cartels end up profiting.
Well, I I don't necessarily think so. I mean, like the cartels
are always going to find ways to make money, etc. But Rogan might
be a sellout now. I don't think Rogan's a sellout. I think that
he's just looking at it from a perspective that's incomplete.
Like, not everybody is a a terrible person, a sellout, a,
you know, some kind of psycho because they have an opinion that's
different than you. Like this is not really that crazy of an
opinion in my opinion. Like it it's not that insane. But I
not everybody's a Jew. Not every listen not everybody's a sellout,
a repbate, a total degenerate or a Jew. Not everybody is like
a totally disgusting
like flimsy excuse for a human soul or a Jew. Not everybody is
a
Not everybody is a Not everybody is, you know, a
a communist or a
that's incomplete. Like not everybody is a terrible person, a
sellout and or you know some kind of psy.
It's really like that. You're not on Twitch, right? I'm just
watching Asmin Gold. Okay. I'm just watching Asmin Gold. That's
all I'm doing here. Is that my I didn't do that. He did that.
He did that, man.
Oh, this Corwin Chelway guy is going to come in and he's going
to dispute both things. Okay. Based Corwin Chelway. Hold on.
Huh. This appears to be like a real person. That's crazy.
All right. Well, Corwin Shel thinks I'm incorrect on a couple
things, so we'll check it out. >> Well, Corwin Shel thinks
I'm incorrect on a couple things, so you are reverbing super
hard. You need headphones.
You are welcome super hard.
>> Maybe better now.
>> Uh maybe better. Let's see. >> Yep. Looks better.
Cool.
>> Oh, I still hear myself, but a little bit better.
You just switch to push to talk if it's a problem.
>> Okay. Yeah. >> Or or you might have to mute the
stream on whatever device you're listening on. >> Normally
been really well done. >> Oh, sorry. Say that again. I
think you're you're listening to me through the stream. You're
probably not hearing me through Discord because it's pretty delayed.
So, just try to see if you can
>> get Discord working for the audio. It's probably your
output device in Discord. >> Yep, you nailed it. >> Okay,
cool. >> I was just playing on
>> Yep, I hear you. Good.
>> Okay, perfect. All right, so you wanted to disagree
on something? >> I was going over just everything you've
gone over the whole last period of time. No, there's no like
one topic where I'm like this is definitely wrong. But you've
just been slowly going over this video and you've had thoughts
and I think I'll I also have slightly
uh you know my thoughts will add to your thoughts I think.
>> Okay, sure.
>> Yeah, go ahead. >> Well, I mean
uh well well we we can talk about stuff from the past. I was
saying just keep going forward with the video. So, um the but
what is >> Sorry, I just the way the call-ins work. Okay,
you call in and like disagree on something, but I I'm don't like
co-host my stream with uh callins.
So, that's it's cool. I appreciate you wanting to come on. Really
appreciate it. But I don't do the I'm not going to go through
the video for content >> through the video. Okay. >> It's
fine if you disagree. If you want to like express a disagreement
or if you want to like give me just a quick thought would also
be fine. Just um something you think adds
But otherwise, yeah, just do it through chat and that's totally
fine. I'll read I'll read your chat messages. I can see >> Okay,
then. Yeah, I'll just use chat.
>> Okay. Well, thanks for coming on. Um, that's fine. I
I think you're new, so like, yeah, sorry if that's a misunderstanding,
but I do appreciate you calling in. Lots of people scared to
call in in the first place. So, W Corin, we get some W. Corwins
in the chat.
Awesome. Okay. Uh, then I'm going to move you back out. I'm probably
gonna continue with the stream. I'll keep an eye out for your
chats in Twitch chat. Okay, thanks for coming on. >> All
right, >> my Discord's like really laggy for some reason.
That guy was cool.
That guy was
All right, cool. Let's uh let's get back to this video. Okay,
as Gold's basically just accusing Joe Rogan of letting his emotions
dictate like his political positions. I think there's some degree.
Okay, this is probably like the
What I say it's like one of the Democrats biggest flaws is they
basically do the same thing without sounding like totally soulless
[__] but they do kind of cut against how people think
emotionally and they say, "Well, that shouldn't be how you think."
And they don't tap into the emotional part at all. So, it's very
interesting that Asminold's going to take the least effective
part of the Democrat playbook and put it into practice for himself.
It's pretty neat. You can make a ton of money online having this
these positions, by the way, but I I think it's generally not
how people vote. It's not how you win elections right now
because they have an opinion that's different than you. Like
this is not really that crazy of an opinion in my opinion. Like
it it's not that insane. But and people say this all the time.
Not people are not because they think what I think. He's not
a a sellout because he's saying this. It's just I I just don't
agree with it. I don't agree with it. And I think that I I think
that this is very there's like a lot of like shortterm or like
face value empathy that people like this have. And I think that
that face value empathy falls apart whenever you investigate
the consequences of it. And I think that the problem is that
a lot of these clips are number one, they're intentionally misleading.
So for example, the woman that was thrown to the ground, theam
Oh, did he cover that story, too? We're going to cover that story.
Okay. He's going to say this woman threw a bottle of water at
a at a moving vehicle. He threw a bottle of water or sorry, she
threw a bottle of water at it, right? It's like, okay, so she
threw a bottle of water at this vehicle. Did that put either
of the agents in like moral danger? Did they have to go slam
this woman to the ground? Really? >> Example that he's
using. This woman was fedally assault. She was assaulting federal
officers. Should should a
>> Dude, there's Yeah, please. I want everybody I want
Asminold to do this. Okay. I want Asminold to be the face of
this. Hey, when you threw your water bottle and it like burst
on their windshield and got water all over their vehicle, that
was assault on a federal officer and you deserve to get slammed
to the ground for it. All right. I want him to own that own that
position.
Like, I'm I'm perfectly willing to say, "Hey, man, maybe that
person should be written up. Maybe that person should be fined.
Maybe they should go." But it's like a fat old white woman. She
ain't running from you guys. Go write her a ticket and be like,
"What the Oh, but they're federal officers, right? They're federal
officers, so I don't even think they can write citations. I think
they just I think they got nothing. And I think they know that.
So, hey, we'll slam her to the ground. We'll detain her and then
we won't charge her with anything. >> Officer allow himself
to be assaulted. Period. Should a person allow themselves to
be assaulted? Period. I think the answer to that is no. I don't
think that they should allow themselves to be assaulted. And
I think the answer is is never. Never should anybody expect to
allow themselves to be assaulted. And whenever she's running
away, she's hysterical. She's screaming at him and he he pushes
her on the ground. Yes, obviously that's what happens. If she
didn't want that to happen, she shouldn't have been grabbing
and screaming at him for the last probably 5 minutes.
Like, why is it always on the >> Wait, is this a is this
a different >> Who is responding to violence to be the
one who measures their response? It's really the person who's
doing it in the first place who's wrong. So, you should look
at why are they doing it?
Forcing your kids to be there. Yeah, 100% with you. She deserved
it. Yeah, you shouldn't have done it in the first
>> Oh, I think he separates himself since Elon Musk took
distance from Trump. I I can't read Joe Rogan's mind. I have
no idea. But like I and I'm not trying to. I'm just I I'm I'm
responding to what he's saying here. And uh if people stopped
allowing their emotions to overtake common sense, we wouldn't
have half the problems that we do today. No, we wouldn't have
99% of the problems that we do today. So, yeah. Uh, I think when
it comes to retroactively deporting people that have been in
the states for years, there could be a merit-based system that
determines the appropriate course of action for them. Well, yeah,
and I agree with you, but I think that the first Okay. So, by
agreeing with that option right there, he already is basically
admitting he banned the previous guy. So he banned another guy
when he said, "Oh, you think uh you think that we should let
people stay here or sorry, what he said was, "You think that
we should let people into this country without checking who they
are at the border?" And the guy said, "No." And he was like,
"Banned him." And now Asminold just admits that, "Oh, I could
totally do a merit system to like let people stay."
>> Step to that merit-based system would be self-deportation.
So for example, I think that if somebody self-deports and they
say, "Hey, I was here for a really long time. I've left, but
you know, I'd like to have a chance to come back. I think that's
totally fine. But the issue is that
by the way,
Canada kind of has this for some things. Not for like illegals,
but like you have to re to become like a Canadian permanent resident.
I think you have to like re-enter the country. There's like places
where you go over the border. You like take a step over and then
you
Yeah. Yeah. And it's like I get the ceremony, but dude, people
live a long way away from the border. What the [__]
This is stupid. Whenever you're not even leaving and you're just
like basically I would not support anything that would give a
advantage to a person who is a criminal and who has abused and
taken advantage of our system because not all of them are kids.
Some of them are kids, but categorically you can't make decisions
based off of the like every every law and every rule is going
to have a certain amount of collateral damage of people that
are
he literally he worked his way from like oh amnesty absolutely
not to like oh yeah in some cases amnesty I would like amnesty
in some places >> and like if you leave it and then ask
to come back then we should let you back in. And it's like, so
you want to just delay this person's life. You want to have a
whole bunch of people leaving and re-entering the country, taking
time off of work so they could go do this trip and like hope
they get let back in and then maybe they don't and their life's
destroyed. I I don't know. Why not just like come up with some
system and then let them stay? Why? You're you're advocating
for something insanely inefficient,
I guess, to penalize people because they made a bad decision
years ago and have been living with it. It just it's totally
inefficient. Now I feel like someone else Now I feel like you
could accuse him of making decisions with his emotions instead
of doing what's rational
by it
That happening is not a justification to just simply get rid
of the rules.
It is still an indirect incentive. Exactly. And Trump has that
as a rule right now. So if you self-deport, you can still have
the chance to come back to America if you follow the procedure
properly. But nobody has a right to just simply skip the line.
There's never any world where somebody has a right to skip the
line. You can't do it in the supermarket. You can't do it at
the bank. You can't do it at a hospital. You can't do it in an
emergency room even. They have to call you in. You can't just
run in there and say, "I need to see a doctor." Uh that's it.
And so it seems like you can listen to their father death at
all.
>> Okay. Okay. So, what's the what's the hypothetical here?
That if somebody like breaks into the hospital, the hospital
does some operation each day to keep them alive. Okay. And they
actually got in by lying. Then we just cut them off, which is
like you're out. You're out. After that,
you can for the owner organ donor list. Yeah. There's uh there's
literally like a merit-based system for deciding who gets organs,
right? They don't call it that. Like it's a criteria or whatever,
but it is like a merit-based system like how how much longer
are you going to be able to use this heart for? What's your health
otherwise?
>> Well, you didn't listen to your father at his deathbed.
What is wrong with you?
This is a uh
what do you think my dad like? So, I I'm going to pull you up
like what a what a weird thing to say. What do you think that
my dad thought about this?
>> I do think it's weird to be like, "Brother, your your
dad would not like this." like right after his dad dies. Brother,
your dad would not appreciate this opinion at all. It's like
I don't care what Asenold's dad's I I don't know what they are.
It's just goofy.
This is This is goofy. Okay. Isaac is weird now. Him. Yeah, I
get it. You guys like totally want to treat people with no empathy.
I get it. I understand.
So, we shouldn't let a lot of a lot of the antisocial type in
chat. Uh, I'm so cool because I have no friends and and nobody
cares about me. I'm so cool.
>> I saw Yeah. So So
>> why are you bringing up my dad? I mean, don't you think
that's weird to say >> Just Asmin? No, it's not just Asmin.
Don't lie to me. It's not just Asmin. There's a lot of other
people. It's not just Asmin Gold that you think that about. You
would say that about a lot of other people. >> I mean,
cuz Yeah. Why would you Why would you even say that? I mean,
do you think that my dad was on like his deathbed and he was
trying to explain to me why we should have let illegal aliens
into the country? Wait, what did his dad say? Did he talk about
like what his dad said to him like as he was dying or something?
Cuz I don't know. I don't even know what this is a reference
to. What are you thinking?
See, and and I think that really this person is a great example
of what I'm talking about is because this person is completely
ruled by their emotions.
They're completely ruled by their emotions and they made the
mistake that I am too.
So, they're trying to use an emotional trick to take advantage
of me and to try to make me disagree with myself,
but I think that the their method of argumentation
is an indicator of their thinking. That's the way that it works.
Hey, pay attention to chat. Yeah, exactly. You see a response.
It doesn't >> No, you guys don't understand. It's because
he's not run by emotion that he could just ban that guy without
arguing anymore. Okay. That's why >> it's just a
look at the name. Haku was a lady boy. I I I don't know about
that. I mean that that's that >> his dad said, "You deal
in hate, son. Turn from that path. Love all." Find me. Find me
where he said that. I don't know. I don't know if I believe that
slime. Find me wherever that example is. >> That's a bit
much. But like what my point is is that there's a lot of emotional
manipulation that goes on. And the moment that you allow people
like that to control you is the moment that you will completely
lose anything that you have. It's grossly manipulative and wrong.
Yes. Exactly. And uh it's AI. It doesn't think. I mean, maybe
you're right. Yeah, I have no idea. And so his comment was inappropriate.
Why'd you ban the previous guy? Because he was Anybody who's
going to go into my stream and argue with me about something
that they don't even think is just wasting my time. I don't like
having fake that guy. That guy could have been referring to like
an amnesty for people who deserve it. And Asold's just like,
"No, you're for even saying no to that question." arguments with
people that don't even believe something in order for them to
get attention on stream. I think that it's a waste of my time
and it's a waste of everybody else's time, too. >> And
so, unless you actually have a belief system that you want to
advocate for in a respectful way, then I don't want to hear your
devil's advocate argument. It's it's it's and it's you don't
even believe your own argument.
Think about that. You you don't even believe what you're saying.
Why are you saying it then? It's a waste of time. So, an orbital
thing say Yeah. Exactly. and and so yeah advocate yeah bring
up fathers thing to do it it doesn't that's not the point right
he's just an idiot who cares but the point is that by doing so
what he's doing is he is indicating >> let's just talk
about >> let me pause this here he's indicating what his
value system is his value system and his currency of value is
is is emotions
>> he wants to manipulate a conversation emotionally
he he's literally describing his feeling and how He feels like
this is not what he signed up for. He's he's explaining how he
feels duped that like when he was told, right, he's literally
getting told like what would happen by Trump, like this is how
immigration was going to work, right, by people around Trump,
by his friends. This is what we mean when we say we want to deport
people. And he's saying, "I am lied to. I feel lied to because
now I see the exact thing that like other people told me would
happen. And I thought they were lying. I thought they were the
people lying." Right? That's what he's describing. He's not just
saying, "Well, now that I see, you know, I really wanted these
people kicked out, and now that I see the bad things happening,
I'm changing my mind." No, he's saying, "I thought it was going
to be criminals. I thought it was going to be the drags of society,
and now I see regular Americans getting kicked out, okay? People
I consider I would like sit down for coffee with and have a good
conversation." Right? That's he's describing that. And Asmin
Gold has no humanity to feel that at all. He wants to control
this emotionally.
He doesn't want to think about this logically or
That's what it is. And so anyway,
I'll show this and and I said before that people would never
accept them back. And this is what this guy is saying. This worthless,
unfunny, cowardly and every other who thinks he's clever or worth
listening to. You don't get to play the liberal after you helped
elect that. You own everything he does. And so there we go again
and again and again. Everybody is
I think I think that's like a silly position to have politically
probably,
right? I understand where it comes from. I understand the emotions
that lead somebody to say that, but it's uh it's just totally
useless. This is why people, you know, people who believe what
slime believes, you know, these super far lefties, you guys will
never have political power, okay? It just won't happen. You might
end up winning in like some revolution where there's a lot of
disperate groups and a lot of like uh internal violence in the
United States. Maybe you guys end up being the party that comes
out on top. Maybe. But you'll never hold like power in any de
democratic system because there are too many of you people who
think that way. It's going to hate you for this. The bridges
are burned. The boats are burned. There's no going back. You've
already decided what you've done. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Hold on.
This is funny. Mass deportations now. Yeah. I don't think Joe
has a lot of excuse for not excuses for not knowing what was
coming. Okay. Like they weren't really hiding it. It's just when
people give him like the bad situation and then Steven Miller
or some maybe Tucker Carlson, somebody close to Joe goes, "No,
no, no. It's not like that at all. It's not like that. You're
totally misunderstanding me." Okay. It's like it's literally
the conversation from It's Always Sunny, right? It's it's literally
the same conversation. Like they are referring to the same thing.
>> Some wax, >> but they are referring to the same
thing. Okay. This is like Steven Miller. This is Joe Rogan. >> I
gloss boat paint. This [__] is really >> Oh,
dude. Yeah, you're telling me I picked this up. Purpose of buying
mattress. I want to get a nice one, too. >> The the what?
The mattress. What do we need a mattress for?
>> What do you mean what do we need a mattress for? Why
in the hell do you think we just spent all that money on a >> Wait,
what do you mean m deportations, dude? Have you not seen Why?
How do you think we're getting votes? We're talking about deporting
everybody. >> Purpose of buying the boat in the first place
was to get the ladies nice and tipsy topside so we can take him
to a nice comfortable place below deck. You know, they can't
refuse because of the implication.
>> Oh. Uh, okay.
You had me go in there for the first part. >> God, it's
all tone. I could like fill in the blanks, right? It's like,
yeah, we're going to get rid of like all of these people who
have ever come in. And Joe's like, "Wait, like all of them? Like
even like what if what if they have like jobs here now? What
if they what if they, you know, pay taxes? What if they're productive
members of society with like families in school here?" And and
then the Republican guy's like, "No, no, no. You're misunderstanding
me. You're misunderstanding me. Like, we'll we'll definitely
target first like the MS-13 people and then eventually all of
the Mexicans will be gone. And so I was like, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, hold on. All of the Mexicans. No, like the MS-13,
Trende Ragua.
Okay. People who have like taken jobs like taken, you know, manufacturing
jobs. We'll those people will be like taken out and and the people
who had those jobs will be put back in and then eventually all
of these brown people will be gone.
>> Every it's just over and over again, right? I don't
even need to finish the clip. Like if you support >> that's
what happened to Joe Rogan is like he basically got coached into
believing that what they were saying out loud wasn't really what
they meant. >> Supported Trump and you were advocating
for him and endorsing him. These people will never forgive you.
They will always hate you. You're never going to get back in
their good graces. And to the extent that you might a little
bit, that's only so they can use you for their own advantages.
You will never be back on their good side. They will never like
you again. It is over and it's been over and it will be over.
>> That's it.
>> I don't know why they don't realize
>> They're delusional. That's how you convert people back
to Democrats. These people don't understand uh how going scorched
earth is a detriment to their own goals. Well, it's because they're
emotional and aggressive. And a lot of these people don't really
care about the issues either. They just care about using the
issues as a weapon to attack other people.
No, it's it's not a big deal. Like I mean I I really mean this
like I
it it's it's just some idiot, right? I mean like why am I going
to care about what some idiot says?
Like I I I wish I >> mean you're referring to it right
now. You're literally caring about you're in the active process
of caring about >> more people had this perspective like
wow somebody on the internet subbed something that was mean
who gives a
who I just stopped yeah what are you even thinking why are you
even thinking about it still who cares so anyway I agree with
you 90% of the arguments the immigration one I just can't I'll
pull up one more one more person and uh this is um this is going
to be good okay cuz I do kind of want to read this Richard Hani
article even though it's going to be like viewership poison in.
All right, there's a Richard Hani article I got here. Hold on,
let me find it. Where did I put it? Where did I Oh, I don't have
it on my front page. Hold on. It's It's on a Substack. It's basically
What is it? It's like um pro brain drain, right?
Let me see here. Let me see here.
Oh, is it was it somebody else? Oh, I'm looking at the wrong
I might be looking at the wrong guy. I I watched an article that
basically showed like how effective America's brain drain is,
but oh, maybe it was the New York Times or something. Maybe it's
a different author. I can't remember. I'll go ahead and I'll
listen to like what you're saying. So, do you think that we should
allow illegal aliens into the country without uh any sort of
like, you know, checking them or anything like that? Emotional
manipulation is a huge tool of cults as well. Most people that
want to activate on your emotions want to do so to subvert your
logic.
They want to take you to a lower form of >> and we would
we would never ever accuse. Okay. Um we'd never try to play on
people's emotions, right?
>> Hold on.
I'm looking for the
looking for the ice video here
in order to change what you believe. I think borders should be
close, but the ones already in should be integrated into society.
So, you think that we should give people that broke the law
and intentionally disrespected our
an advantage in immigration
over people that have followed the law and tried to go through
the immigration process
If it's beneficial to the people of the United States in the
short and medium term, I believe so. The argument would be it's
in the long term, right? And this is why they say, "Oh, we're
only going to do one amnesty, right?" But like, if it's beneficial
to the United States to keep that person, then yeah, obviously.
And as can't even argue about this, right? Because you'd have
to say, "Okay, we find out Elon Musk is a an illegal immigrant.
He actually doesn't he's not legal in the United States. We didn't
know this. Nobody really checked. They just trusted. Are we deporting
him and not taking his taxes anymore?
Are we going to do that?" Not that I I kind of doubt that Elon
pays much in taxes, but like we would you just do that? Doesn't
really seem to make sense,
>> You think we should give people that are in the country
illegally already priority over them? Obviously not. Okay. So
then you Well, if you're not in favor of that,
if you're Wait a minute. So if you're not in favor of that, then
how could you advocate for it? Hold on. Hold on. I just wanted
to, you know, uh, emotional manipulation is the tool of cults.
It's, uh, it's what people do when they try to like lie to you.
Oh, really? What What were these videos for? Jarant, we're taking
our country back. Thank you for your attention to this matter.
Department of Homeland Security.
>> This is the Department of Homeland Security, the official
Twitter of the Department of Homeland Security
>> posting memes.
>> I get the bag and flip it and tumble it straight off
the lot
and she got
a bag. Pull up to the spot too fast
in Italy.
Why don't they Can somebody tell me why they don't do the videos
of like Why don't they do the videos of like a child crying while
they're like 45year-old glasseswearing kind of fat dad gets deported
out of the country? Why don't they do that video? Is there a
reason?
Oh. Oh. Cuz like nobody likes watching that. It looks way better
when you try to imply all deportations are just criminals. Wow.
Obviously not. But the sisting friend to America is completely
it's almost impossible to everyone to get to America without
crossing the border violating law. So you think that like
let me go let me just look it up.
How many people immigrate
into the US per year legally?
So over a million people. There's over a million people that
have done it legally right here.
So, if it's so impossible to do, then how are a million people
doing it? >> Bro, we just we just groed it. That problem
that problem just got grocked.
I By the way, I don't really have a huge problem with AI if he's
going to click
>> And also, here's another question that I have sources.
Why is it our country's responsibility and obligation in order
to provide the entire world with an easy an easy an easy way
to immigrate into our country? What obligation do we have to
the rest of the world to allow them to come here? Why do we have
an obligation to make an easy immigration system for people to
come into our
Like take a step back and ask yourself that question.
True. I can't argue it's emotionally based thinking for the most
part, but it just feels wrong putting fathers that didn't do
any crime in America just to deport them. I don't know, man.
Well, they did do crime. They shouldn't be. The million people
include TP TPS and visa and asylum seekers. Hold on a second.
Temporary protected status. Got it. So, that would be I don't
know what the difference is between TPS and asylum seekers in
general, but interesting. here. And also a lot of people that
uh and and this is also a really big thing that a lot of people
don't understand is that a lot of the people that are here illegally
do actually engage in crime regularly. They engage in identity
theft. They engage in other forms of misrepresentation of themselves.
They don't maybe pay taxes in the same way that they should.
Like for example, if you're an illegal alien and you're working
here under the table, you're probably not paying into social
security, which means that all
I listen,
I think that's the one thing from what I understand, illegal
immigr uh illegal aliens, if they're not like just working the
absolute bottom of the barrel jobs, they kind of do cuz I think
that's like the one case where you get cuted.
All right. The US has a good idea of where all the money is going
and I do think they I do think they actually make sure people
are paying taxes. They also won't take out of social social security.
I believe they won't. Yeah. He raifies logic is the ultimate
moral good because it is ostensibly divorced from emotion. But
the actual logic employed in this in his argument reduces down
to it is illegal to be an illegal immigrant equals we should
deport them. That isn't even logic. That is a tautology that
he's trying to make normative. The logical argument would be
involving involve moving past the oneline illegal
equals bad argument he's doing. Yeah. Sure. What what he's doing
is not logic. It's prima fascia acquiescence to the law. Sure.
And he's saying that like there is no understandable circumstance
where you wouldn't want to look at the law. He's saying that
like and realistically it's not even like
it's not like something that carries a sentence. It's not like
you're going to say oh you broke into the country we're putting
you in jail. Right? It's like you broke into the country we're
kicking you out of the country. It's not like you are harming
other people significantly or in a direct way.
Yeah, I do think that's a good point to make though that basically
he's trying you see him trying to evade even that part, Marty,
cuz he's trying to say, well, actually illegal immigrants aren't
even just doing the one crime. It's like technically they they
probably aren't paying taxes cuz they don't have a social security
number, right? Or they're doing identity theft to get a social
security number so they can pay taxes illegally. They're just
doing crimes. It's basically all crimes that are from the initial
tree of immigrating illegally,
right? Yeah. Also, your employer is paying into social security
either. Not every illegal alien is paying taxes. So, by creating
by allowing people to come into the country illegally, you're
also creating a second order effect of increasing the demand
for stolen identities and fake IDs and other forms of fraudulent
documentation.
because many of them actually do commit crimes. It's just that
they're not committing crimes like robbery or murder. Well, I
don't know. And and you can see it is emotionally it feels wrong.
Well, it it's not about what fe like how things feel.
Yeah. I could have sworn that you can contact the IRS basically
for like a I don't know if they assign you a social security
number, but you can basically pay taxes. Like they they like
work it out. As far as I know, like the IRS doesn't really ask
any other questions or provide that information to like any other
investigators. They basically just go like, "Uh, listen, you're
a drug dealer. Well, we still like money. We still like getting
taxes. So, if you want to pay us money as a drug dealer, we'll
take it.
Shouldn't like how does how does that feel wrong to you?" But
us having the resources because the logic, right, the logic very
clearly is that the person that's immigrating into the country
is >> Oh, isn't the IRS sharing data with DHS now, though?
Uh that sounds like not something the IRS would uh would want
to do. If they're doing that, they're being like coerced because
they're a part of the exe executive, I assume.
Um that would be [__] up. That would be really [__]
up. Find me an article on that.
Just because like the whole reason I think illegal immigration
can arguably work is because you do let them pay taxes. If you're
now going to go after those people who are paying taxes, you're
literally finding a list of the exact people you should be trying
to retain in your country, right? the people who at risk to themselves
trusted the government and decided to actually pay taxes.
That's that's literally the list of people you should not be
deporting. They took the actual list of people that you should
be keeping and they're like, "Well, MS-13's hard to catch." They're
like, "They don't really identify themselves. Let's deport all
the people who pay taxes."
Seriously.
Okay. That's that sounds like on a bookkeeping note that just
sounds but okay. is now going to have a better life because they're
in the country. How is it fair that we allocate resources to
improving the life of a random foreigner over improving the life
of a homeless
Because the veteran costs money purely. A homeless veteran costs
money purely. The foreigner is paying money in and not collecting
benefits.
Like essentially not collecting benefits at all.
That's how you pay for that homeless dude is somebody else pays
for his benefits while they're awaiting benefits. This person's
not even guaranteed to be awaiting benefits.
That's like the whole point. That's how the system works. Bro,
hold on. Let's take a look at this real quick. It is a little
bit related. IRS begins sharing sensitive taxpayer data with
immigration authorities to find undocumented migrants. The Internal
Revenue Service began sharing sensitive taxpayer data this week
with immigration authorities searching for undocumented migrants.
According to two sources familiar with the matter, as part of
President Donald Trump's massive deportation push, the Treasury
Department and the Department of Homeland Security signed an
agreement in April to turn over information about undocumented
immigrants who DHS says are already facing deportation orders
and are under federal criminal investigation. So, I guess this
would be with the caveat that they're saying, "Hey, we only want
info on the people that were already committing crimes." I assume
they mean more than just being here illegally, being in the US
illegally, right? They probably don't.
But
oh man, this this sounds like the worst poss the worst of all
worlds,
It says facing deportation orders and are already under federal
criminal investigation. I kind of I don't believe it necessarily.
100 billion is a lot though. Let's see. What is this?
Oh yeah. Damn. study says undocumented immigrants paid almost
a hundred billion dollars in taxes. I would just say how do you
get an estimate over of like how much they cost the system, right?
Would be interesting to know. It' just be Yeah, interesting to
know. Uh I guarantee you, okay, that number with this news, that
number is going to be significantly cut into.
How much did Doge save overall, by the way?
Can we do we have figures on that for how much Doge cut from
the budget?
Which, by the way, those were all productive like programs in
some way or another? What? There's no way it's only 1.4 billion.
There's no way it's 1.4 billion. There's no shot
that they only save 1.4 billion.
What?
Anywhere from 20 to 60 billion. So, like all of DOA's work might
be undone just by this incredibly short-sighted, ideologically
motivated, emotionally driven policy, right? Oh, IRS IRS has
records of some of these people. They pay taxes. Let's start
sharing that with with DHS.
Neat. Neat. Oh,
all right. Anyway, let's continue with this video. I don't I
I don't I don't view that as an emotionally sound decision. I
don't see that as a morally good or emotionally uh you know congruent
decision
because I I I think that we do live in a world of uh
of opportunity cost.
Everything is a zero sum environment. There's only so much money.
There's only so many no no
economics is explicitly not a zero- sum environment. That is
the entire
this guy. You can tell this guy's literally never taken a single
economics class. Holy [__]
bro.
And by the way, I'm somebody who actually believes despite I
don't share his opinion, but I I know there are downsides to
illegal immigration. I know there are downsides to large amounts
of legal immigration for regular citizens, but it is never ever
ever
just a zero- sum game. Somebody's going to benefit. There will
be large benefits to the system. And there's this whole economy
or sorry there's this whole concept of economies of scale right
like you just need to know about the concept of economies of
scale and why cities took off as economic centers to understand
that having more people who could do more work and be more productive
as a society is always effective. It's always good is it always
it's always good in aggregate for the society. Is it always good
for every individual person's happiness? No. But knowing when
it uh when adding a person or taking away a person is like beneficial
that's really difficult to argue. But calling it a zero- sum
game is abs like actually kind of just disqualifies him entirely
as a political commentator
referring to like yeah it's it actually just totally disqualifies
you resources there's only so many things scarcity exists with
everything. So whenever you're applying this to one person you're
choosing not to apply it to someone else
and I just can't see that being >> this is literally and
I know my chat's going to get triggered because I got a lot of
leftists now. This is communist thinking. This is like the kind
of thinking communists do all the time. Oh no, we just need to
close the economy because things are scarce. Things are really,
really scarce and we don't want to deal with that. Okay, we have
to save everything. We have to save it all for ourselves. No,
that's like this is so
The right decision.
Why veteran? Because they effective because they they directly
serve the country. If they do crimes, they should be in jail
no matter what they are. It doesn't matter if they're legal or
illegal. Well, yeah. I mean, I think that's obviously true. I
mean, everybody agrees with that.
The Trump administration is doing so much commocialist [__]
right now. They might be, but the unfortunate thing is they're
also doing they're also doing like the banana republic of just
raiding the wealth of the nation as much as they possibly can,
right? Like honestly, is this a sign of like America falling
as an empire? Is they've just got a government there that's going
to steal as much money as they can? And I assume run. I assume
like after this government's finished, I actually think that
people will come back and prosecute them. So, I assume they're
going to run,
but like is this are do they think they can pull enough money
out of this country that they can make it fail? I don't even
I don't know. I don't see how that could be possible. Right.
Here's a more uh detailed for thing for anyone
Oh, it's the 100 billion input from undocumented migrants is
or immigrants is a well sourced document. Okay. Yeah. Check that
out if you guys want. >> Yeah. And uh yeah, of course.
And also like you have and and I do think this is something that's
true is that I think that if your family like if you're an American
citizen, your parents are American citizens,
I think that the country has an obligation to you to take care
of you. And I I know people might not agree with this or think
it's communism or socialism or anything, but I do think the country
has an obligation to take care of you because your country your
your family has lived and died in this country. They pay taxes
into this country. Your grandfather paid taxes into the into
the same government that right now is real.
Everybody believes this. Literally everybody believes this. You're
just saying something that is tautologically true for every single
Yeah, the government should take care of you. You pay taxes in,
the government should take care of you, right? You're a productive
member of society. The government should help you. Everybody
believes this. It's like obviously there's uh more than just
the what would you call it? The um
this isn't just a pleasantry. It's like a virtue signal, right?
How you actually display that by what you advocate for is what
actually matters. You just saying, "Oh, I want the government
do I want government do good." Yeah, everyone want government
do good. Asmin Gold, can you go a little deeper? Can we go a
little deeper than just government? Listen, guys. I just want
government do good. Don't you want government do good? Platitude
was the word I was looking for. Thank you, full of hell. Sometimes
the thesaurus in my brain breaks and I can't I can't think of
like the specific word I'm thinking of. I don't know how I don't
know how to fix it. Okay, it just started happening. I I don't
know how to explain it, man.
Okay, but I like it. I like it when government do good. Government
do good equals good. I am happy when government do good. >> Your
money to Israel. They're reallocating your money to some other
foreign government or
>> Dude, when you combine this with like the comment from
earlier, dude, I need to actually clip that Jew com that was
so funny to me. Uh, I like have to go back and find that again.
Holy [__] that was funny.
>> Hold on. I'm gonna go find a foreigner instead of you.
>> And I consider that a betrayal. I think that is a betrayal.
It's a fundamental
>> And it's a betrayal that's done in the disguise of empathy,
but I actually think that it's the opposite. So that that's that's
my viewpoint. And so a lot of these opinions that I have. >> So
this can happen. There is a thing called ruinous empathy that
does affect people. They will make decisions that are long-term
bad for them based on their emotions, right?
But like ultimately, there are things that could be long-term
bad for you that you make an emotional decision on that are a
part of the human experience that are a part of being a good
person and make life worth living. Okay? We're not we're not
just interchangeable economic units. Okay? This guy sometime
his thinking changes from like different ideologies. I don't
know why he's doing some WF Claus Schwab interchangeable economic
unit thing here where he's like, "Listen, guys, I I shouldn't
I don't have to care about the uh the parents being ripped away
from their kids. I don't have to think about that. That's just
people trying to use my emotions against me. Don't they understand
that the interchangeable economic units that are white Americans
are being hurt by these other interchangeable economic units
from this other country and we have to have loyalty to our interchangeable
economic units?"
I don't know. There's there's like another there's a complex
thing going on there. Okay.
When human beings become like totally unwilling to risk any harm
to themselves and they're they're purely selfish all the time,
that's like when a society has failed, right?
I think that's probably like everybody. This is the one thing
that I don't necessarily disagree with the um with like the incelss
or racists, okay? I'm I'm of one mind with legal mindset on this
one thing, okay? And that's that high trust societies are pretty
cool and I think they're like I would love to be able to go back
to that at some point, right? Like a high trust society where
there's not a bunch of racial tension, where there's not a bunch
of like going on. If you could somehow combine that with not
being, you know, if you could somehow do that with a multi-thnic
society, that's like the best of all worlds. We all want that,
right?
Anyway, anyway, hold on. >> That's incomplete. Like not
everybody is a a terrible person to sell out a or you know some
it's so good. It's like the
uh not everybody is one of these disgusting
pieces of God. It's it's just so good. It's so fun. >> And
this is one of the issues that I that I have too is that um
I think that a lot of people attack me and they say that I'm
not empathetic or whatever or something like that. I think that
I'm one of the only people that is >> what? Oh, what? What?
Pac-Man. Pack the man. What he said was not everybody in society
is a terrible person, a sellout or a
he continues on. I'm not even joking that he just continues on
after that statement. Like it's not like it's uh that's in >> Listen
again. Hold on. Let me let me turn it up. Listen >> complete.
Like not everybody is a a terrible person, a sellout and or you
know some kind of psycho because they have an opinion that's
different than you. Like this is not really that crazy
>> Oh, he added one more. Some kind of psycho. Listen,
I don't know what to say to that anymore. Okay, I'm going to
continue on with this. >> I have not asold is the one with
real empathy because he's thinking about you in the future. Okay,
that's why we have to deport all these people because he's thinking
about you in the future. the issues that I that I have too is
that um
I think that a lot of people attack me and they say that I'm
not empathetic or whatever or something like that. I think that
I'm one of the only people that is.
>> I do. >> I think nobody else is actually empathetic.
They don't really think about how things are. They just act based
off of how they feel at that moment. They don't try to actually
improve the lives of anybody. They don't try to look at what's
right or what's wrong other than just the surface value uh you
know immediate you know instant opinion they have
so yeah and uh that's it you see cause and effect yes it's performative
yeah >> guys I I'm thinking of my emotions 30 years from
now I am the person with actual empathy because I'm thinking
about how we'll both feel feel 30 years from now okay >> and
I think that's why they hate me is because I'm one of the only
people that can see that it's performative.
Many other people don't call that out, but I can see it because
I I know that because again like I can kind of do that myself.
And that's why like this is um
dude this is like I'm just picturing Asmin Gold on the Titanic
getting into a lifeboat and being like listen I'm thinking about
the long-term prospering of all people in America for me being
able to continue to pay my taxes. Okay. Okay. He's like lecturing
a 5-year-old girl as he takes her spot in the lifeboat and he
puts her back on the Titanic and he's like, "Listen, I'm just
thinking about the long-term flourishing of humanity from me
being able to continue doing my job. You You're really unproven.
I'm thinking about everybody else right now. Okay? I understand
that you're going down with the ship and I need to get off on
this boat. Like, we have to think about what's best for everybody.
Okay? Okay, little girl. So, you have to stay here. You have
to go down with the ship. I'm going to go and live and it's going
to work out best for everyone." Also, a car alarm just started
going off in my parking lot. Give me a second. Make sure it's
on my vehicle
into the same government that right now is reallocating your
money to Israel. They're reallocating your money to some other
foreign fun. What an odd time to what an odd random time stamp.
I just clicked in this thing.
This guy said vehicle. Dude, apparently people, it's so funny
that one of the arguments people had about the uh the Tyler Robinson
guy being like an FBI scop that like he wasn't real was his text
messages used vehicle or something instead of instead of car.
I use vehicle all the time. I'm not an FBI agent. I swear to
God I'm not
That's very interesting. Okay, now to top this all off just as
a last sort of like a capstone to the segment. Okay, we're going
to check out this channel. This liberal hivemind channel. I pulled
it up before. It's sort of Chicago PD teargast. What? Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Trump's masked ice gestapo. Iapo paramilitant
SS. Okay.
Okay. Please don't. Please don't be super soy with the start.
Like I It's bad enough. I can see it's bad. You don't have to
do all of the things. Okay. A paramilitant SS tier gas. a pair
of radical left furry transif
you can you chill can you chill dog
>> these were uh Chicago PD officers getting tear gas
>> they just tear gas you don't give a [__]
about you either while you
>> that's kind of rough that's kind of rough all right
anyway we have this li this liberal hivemind channel. Okay, this
is like my new Asmin slop channel. I don't know if this guy was
a liberal. It seems like he's an I left the left type. Okay.
Former liberal looking to shine the light. Shine light on the
hypocrisy that pushed me away from the
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. And he's just got a whole bunch of Asmin slop tier videos.
This guy is like right-wing Midas touch over here. Okay.
All right. So, I wanted to check out uh which one was it? It's
like about people faking. Yeah, it never actually happened. All
right. It never It never actually happened. I think it's going
to go around to a bunch of these and sort of try to debunk them
and we'll see if if there's like solid debunking or weak debunking.
All right.
Okay. Give me two seconds. I need to use the bathroom real quick
and then I'll be right back. I'll be right back. New Hunter Avalone
Grift. Maybe let's see the Hassan vids. Maybe we can check those
out, too. Hold on. I'll be right >> Hey guys, welcome to
the Liberal Hiveminded channel solely focused on exposing the
abundant hypocrisy of the left. Well, of course, we got another
week. Therefore, it's another mountain of Democrat lies, another
day, another fake narrative, more Democrat duplicity meant to
lead the public astray for political purposes. And of course,
once again, this time it's not just coming from some random internet
libtard. No, it's yet again another top sitting Democrat official.
Just the other day it was Dan Goldman, right? And well, today
it's Waqen Castro. These people cannot help themselves. They
lie, distort, deliberately misframe everything to turn reality
upside down. Because of course, without the lies, they're pathetic
little power-grabbing narratives collapse. And so, let's do what
we always do. Let's tackle the latest examples of malicious Democrat
disinformation. More proof that these people will twist. >> Okay.
Okay. Okay. Tell me that this channel is not going to be gold.
I found this channel. I watched like two minutes of a video and
I'm like, "Oh, this is a gold mine. This is an actual gold mine
right here." Okay,
this guy is still kicking. Oh, I'd never seen this channel before,
but I I'm definitely >> doing absolutely everything and
anything to shield themselves from scrutiny to protect the chaos
that they've created to defend criminals, to attack the people
who are trying to undo the damage that they have caused. Let
me show you guys exactly what's going on. We got some stuff to
get into. >> Are you sure it's not a parody? Oh, no, it's
not a parody. All right, folks. So, let's start off with this
post from Congressman Wen Castro. Again, not just some random
far-left lunatic on Tik Tok. No, a federally elected Democrat
who posted this photo trying to drum up outrage as a masked ICE
agent pointed a gun at a US citizen because she was filming him.
Now, let me ask you, does that look like a gun? No, of course
not. That's not a looks like a non-lethal or a less than lethal
like either sandbag or or not sandbag but um we call it like
bean bag or like paintball pepper ball round weapon like a crowd
control weapon is what it looks like. Firearm that's a modified
paintball gun meant to non-lethal crowdontrol pellets. And these
tools of course are only deployed during very specific times,
right? during riots. And of course, I guess, >> oh, was
there a riot here? Okay, hold on. Was there a riot? It looks
like he's pointing at another car. I see like there's somebody
in a car here, right? Was were they rioting in this car? That's
pretty crazy to just get in a car and riot like that. He wants
us to forget the last, I don't know, six, seven months of riots
from attacks on Tesla facilities to now the endless attacks on
ICE agents and federal facilities. This shot of course happened
during a riot where Antifa and the open borders mob continue
to descend on that ICE facility in Chicago. These agents are
under attack last week. They were
>> where where they're literally beside it looks like they're
sitting in traffic, dog. Where's the Where's the riots? >> Under
attack. Their cars being rammed, rocks being thrown at them.
One individual had a freaking assault rifle. And yet here we
have a little Democrat, Mr. Castro here just taking a still frame
completely out of context attempting to paint ICE agents as >> Wait,
so he's got like he's Oh, it's way out of context. So, you've
got the context to show us what's going on, right? I assume so.
I assume there's going to be like way more context. Oh, no. He's
going to say, "Hey, I'm talking about things that have happened
and pretending that they apply to this situation with no other
knowledge." Oh, yeah. I looked at the reflection. Yes, it's clear
that these guys are like sitting in [__] traffic
as the aggressors. Yo, they were just filming him and so he pulled
out a gun. What a liar. Then of course, let's move to the next
point of fake outrage. We've got this clip here of a If only
we hadn't watched them. Okay, this might this might work a little
bit. All right,
if we hadn't watched Ice pull over, like switch lanes, ram into
that woman, drive forward a little bit, get out with their guns
drawn, and rip her out of her vehicle.
Right. We we literally watched that happen. Like yes, they have
pulled their guns on people for no reason when they're in the
wrong. Yes, >> priest. That's what they keep calling him,
but from my understanding, he's a pastor, but you know, semantic.
>> Are we going to pretend that priests and pastors are
the same? Like, like that's a really critical element to the
story. He's a pastor and not a priest. It's very critical. >> More
importantly, this guy got shot in the head with a pepper ball.
>> And Democrats are posting this all over social media.
clearly attempting to weaponize the optics here. This
Okay, so hold on. The optics here are this guy looks relatively
peaceful like he's protesting. There's no evidence of property
damage, no evidence of escalation, no evidence of people trying
to break in. No evidence that there's any threat to the ICE officers
currently. And it looks like they shoot this guy in the head
because he's yelling up at them.
But that's that's just the optics. This guy's going to tell me
what actually happened. Hold on. guy who's laring as some sort
of religious figure got shot in the head with a pepper ball.
Again, a non-lethal crowdcontrol tool and people are pretending,
oh, it was totally unprovoked. But it wasn't. These people have
been told repeatedly, "Do not cross the line. Do not step off
that sidewalk. Do not come on federal property. There has been
an order to deal with anybody who steps on these federal properties
during these riots." And this individual was warned multiple
times, ignored, but of course, he stepped over. He's taunting
the officers on top. >> Now, hold on. Hold on. Wait, wait,
wait. Uh, hold on. I've got Okay. What does this sound like?
Listen. Uh, listen. On this day, okay, on this day,
June 5th, 1989, there were riots. There were riots happening
all over. Okay? And we told this guy, we told him, "Listen, if
you stand in the street, just like Asmin Gold said,
you're going to get flattened. Okay? You're going to get flattened
if you stand in the street like this. All right? And that man
defied the law. And of course, we had no choice. Okay? No matter
how much threat he presented to us. We had no choice but to exert
force on this person. Okay? This guy's describing, of course,
Tianaan Square in 1989. All right. It was actually illegal for
this guy to be standing here. So, they had to run him over with
those tanks. That's just a require. It's a hard requirement.
Okay? It doesn't matter what threat that guy presents.
That guy has to be dealt with. He broke the rules. And there's
only one option when people break the rules. I don't know this
guy. I think this guy might sweep for anything. If he's just
like, "Oh, actually, um, they're not supposed to be on that property,
so they shot this guy in the head with a paintball for the roof."
You can see. And again, a non-lethal deterrent was used. The
same tactics you'd see from any riot police department. But suddenly,
oh, it's proof of the Gustapo. Donald Trump's Gustapo persecuting
a holy man. How ridic. I mean, it kind of is though. >> It
literally It literally kind of is. Yo, Marmma, dude, thank you
for the gifted sub. Thank you. Thank you. Thank >> Ridiculous.
Again, you see >> and anonymous. Thank you for another
gifted sub. Hold on. I'll tell you guys how far we are from meeting
the goal. We got 17
27 28. We'll say that's 30. We
>> six subs. Six subs for another two hours on the stream,
guys. Six subs away. Let's go. Get those subs in. Get the donations
in. Appreciate all the support. gonna continue. >> See
how they constantly try to pick at your emotional heartstrings.
The way they weaponize optics, the way they take this specific
case just because this man presents himself as a whole. By the
way, again, I'm just I'm telling you guys how this is. All right?
This is literally the exact playbook that Israel tried to run
and failed to through the entire ground assault in Gaza. It's
how they burned up all of their political capital. It's how they
lost the entirety of the planet of Earth. Okay? Everybody thought
Israel had a right to defend itself on October 7th, 2023. And
by the modern day, basically every country on this planet is
like, "Yeah, you guys are you guys really like this is disgusting.
We can't conscience this anymore." Okay? This is it's unconscionable
and it's not going to work for Republicans, okay? And obviously,
you know, the the the war crimes of Israel significantly worse.
But I'm telling you that this is so outside of what Americans
expect to happen to protesters. Like, you can't defend this.
You can't
holy figure and then try to weaponize
Oh, I mean maybe I I guess maybe Republicans could justify this
guy getting shot with a pepper ball. Okay, maybe you could they
could justify this guy, but the people getting like pulled out
of their vehicles and the people getting with waiting for the
kids at school. Yeah, that's not going to work, >> Religion
against the right, but they do it so clearly, dishonestly, and
maliciously. It's not complicated. After months of violent demonstrations,
assaults on officers, last week's outright terror attack on ICE
officers in Chicago, not to mention the shooting. Wait, wait,
wait. What's the terror attack on ICE officers in Chicago?
Wait, what am I missing? There's a terror attack on ICE officers
in Chicago. I didn't hear about that one. If he mentions the
Dallas thing, that's also >> what happened in Texas at
the ICE facility. Federal agents have been given the order to
secure these facilities and they've said it over and over and
over again on loudspeaker.
>> Where where who who was shot again? Multiple immigrants
were shot at that ICE facility. >> Do not cross the line.
They've set up barricades and this guy decided to test that of
course to poke the bear. And what happened? Exactly what should
happen in this case. There was a lawful order and you decided
not to listen to that authority, that authoritative command.
So of course you're going to fafo. This is typical leftist stupid
games. Stupid. >> Okay, now I'm going to give you guys
license to do something that I've never done on this channel
before, but it's actually not cringe. Okay, at this point in
time, you can actually call this guy a bootlicker. This is actual
bootlicking. Okay, I think leftist run to this term at the second
anybody is like, "Yeah, I expect the cops to do their job." Okay,
they love running to this term. But right now, this is actual
bootlicking. He's like coming up with totally [__]
contrived
possibilities for why they decided to this guy. It's like, "No,
tell me what he did. Don't tell me about a shooting in Dallas
that might put them on edge. Tell me what the [__]
this guy did to deserve getting shot in the face." Well, uh,
they said don't go over the line and then he stepped over the
line and so they could shoot him in the face and risk blinding
him. Okay. Yeah, that's what I think. >> Surprises, but
they want to pretend as if it's the fault of fascism again. Absolutely
pathetic.
not trying to defend any side, what should happen. Um, I would
imagine your deterrence are proximal to the threat faced by you
and how much the other side's escalating and like what is currently
happening with the the protest overall. Like the protest is remaining
peaceful. If these people are just chanting and there's nothing
violent happening, there's no escalation,
right?
Then obviously you don't need to shoot somebody in the forehead
with a pepper ball.
You are you are the one escalating at this point. This is what
we talked about in Portland is that hey, unlike in 2020 when
I saw Antifa escalating at a whole bunch of a whole bunch of
the protests all over the place, right? Or even in uh in 2016,
2018 as well, dude. Like whenever I've seen the BLM protests
happening, it's like I see a lot of escalating from protesters
in a bunch of this stuff with ICE. I don't see people escalating.
I see ICE escalating every
And guess what? the people who are like acting, who are escalating
way out ahead of what the other side's doing, they're going to
more often than not appear to be in the wrong. >> Classic
narrative spin. And really, there's a theme here. It's misplaced
outrage. They want you outraged at the
>> So, they can't place a line you can't cross. They can
come in for dinner. No. Um, I would say your line is your fence
right here, right?
If you if you have nobody down there and there's just like a
line you you painted on the ground or you chocked on the ground.
You're like if you cross that I'm going to shoot you in the head,
right?
Like I'm going to risk blinding you because you think it's an
important thing to make a statement to to cross over that line.
I don't know if you know this. The entire purpose of this protest
is to say like you ICE, [__] you. You're violating
our civil liberties. So if you went through the fence, it's fine.
Yes. If they started trying to breach the fence, then I think
that's an escalation on their side.
But if you pray, if you place, okay, this is like if you place
an artificial line with no barrier there, right? You say, "If
you cross that, I'm going to be really mad at you." People are
going to cross it. That's naturally going to happen, right?
wrong thing. These Democrats should be outraged over these ICE
facilities being attacked and ransacked, over these ICE officers
being assaulted in the streets, facing a heightened terror risk.
Attacks on federal officers are up over 1,000%.
But instead, know they want you outraged over an outof contacts
on Bro, I've seen what they're reporting is attacks on federal
officers. They literally run into somebody else's car and they
go, "Oh, that's an attack on a federal officer. Book them." Yeah,
of course they're up a thousand%. They're using it as their pretext
for all of their actions. Oh, actually, you just tried to assault
a federal officer.
Uh, this is why Republicans think this guy should be pepper balled.
Let's take a look. Uh, he's a professional communist Antifa agitator
who professionally gets pepper-sprayed in the face while cl while
wearing clerical shirts for photo ops. He's done this several
times already.
What is this? Ice sprays directly in the face of the lead pastor
for First Presbyterian in Chicago. This photo will go down well,
I believe, will go down in history.
Do you think it's possible that he is a pastor who also believes
that these violations of civil liberties can't be conscenced?
They they can't be they can't be
Chicago First Church Pastor Black. Hold on. Hold on.
Like, it's entirely possible he's just a literal pastor who thinks
like, "Hey, this is really bad."
It turns out pastors do have political beliefs. They're human
beings.
They are They are in fact human beings, guys.
Oh, what was the other one? Says a BLM mask. What? Oh, black
lives matter. Yeah, dude. I can't believe a religious person
thinking black lives matter. Could you imagine?
Oh my god. Woke pastor. Got it.
Dude,
it's
uh
it's I just, you know, I prefer the pastor who like sells me,
you know, survi my like products for my uh for my doomsday shelter.
I prefer the pastor who sells me the same products as Alex Jones.
Okay. The guy who does it out of a mega church and sells me a
bunch of markedup survival stuff. That's my version of a pastor.
That guy's the actual moral. That guy's my actual moral >> X
little snippet, a frame, or some weaponized little optics play
here involving this priest. Or the latest little manufactured
outrage campaign, the fake hysteria over Donald Trump's comments
about arresting Brandon Johnson and JB Pritsker. >> The
president of the United States in the last 24 hours called for
you to be imprisoned. Um, I want to give you an opportunity to
senior reaction on social media, but um, I want to hear what
you have to >> Why does he say like, "Oh, this is um, I
hate online.
I hate this." I probably do it. Okay, I probably do the same
thing. But sometimes people will all they'll do is they'll repeat
the thing that's being like claimed with a incredulous voice
and then they never elaborate in any way and it's like, "Yeah,
you can do that. You can just go, "Oh, yeah, you're just you're
you're mad because Trump's calling for you to be jailed, Mr.
Pritsker. That's it." It's like, you can do that, but how does
anybody like that when they don't make any Like, do you have
Say something else?
Say anything else.
>> to say back to the president of the United States.
>> Let's start with the idea that this is a convicted felon.
I mean, think about that. Who is threatening to jail me?
I got to say this guy's unhinged. He's insecure. He's a wannabe.
>> Is he crazy? Is he crazy? Is it unhinged? Is it totally
insane?
>> And there's one thing I really want to say to Donald
Trump. If you come for my people, you come through me. So come
and get me. >> Then come all the Democrats. We got Massachusetts
Governor Mora Haley hitting us with her pearl clutching response.
Never in history of our great country has a president threatened
to jail a governor for disagreeing with him. For dis
>> see he's he's literally saying he's literally doing
the >> agreeing with him. You say these people are so dis
okay he has to of course he's going to show us what JB Pritzkar
is doing cuz even I could do it right. I could make the argument
that like oh well JB Pritsker you know refuses to let local police
refuse to nationalize the guard. He's putting ICE agents at risk.
I you got to at least know those points. You can't just sound
incredulous when you read the tweets, man. >> Don is spare
me this nonsense, please. JB Pritsker and Brandon Johnson have
been harboring criminals, illegal aliens. They've federal agents.
There was a literal terror. >> Okay, thank [__]
god. He says something. This guy's doing the uh the nu bit. ambush
on ICE officers just last week and we covered the leaked directive
and police communications where Chicago PD was ordered to stand
down. The call came from the tippy top in Chicago leadership.
They refused to assist officers who were under attack. All of
those actions could easily be viewed as obstruction of justice,
defiance of federal law. And so Donald
No, no, they can't. Well, Trump's righteous call for accountability
is now threatening to jail a governor for quote disagreeing with
him. Again, misplaced outrage. The outrage should be at JB Pritzker
and Brandon Johnson, who are both right now probably the biggest
clowns in Democrat politics. But instead, orange man bad. Democrats
clearly don't care about the law. All they care about is optics.
And of course, continuing with this, >> does this guy not
realize that it's like
that like a federal court said Trump couldn't nationalize the
couldn't um is it federalized the National Guard or whatever?
It's like taking control of the National Guard in Oregon, right?
Has that happened now? Have they taken over or is it like still
actually a contested matter of law whether or not these ICE agents
or any of these people could even act in any capacity in these
cities? >> Trend of misplaced outrage. You'll see it all
over social media. You got the president doing the right thing,
tackling crime, and then you've got Chicago leadership acting
in defiance. But these Democrats, they're outraged over Donald
Trump's invasion. >> Donald Trump is invading Illinois.
He's ordered hundred. >> Oh, they can't deploy them. Okay.
>> Hundreds of troops to be sent in from Texas without
our consent or coordination. We are fighting back with everything
we have and we've already filed lawsuits against him. But I want
to make this crystal clear.
Uh, I think here's the thing, okay? I want Donald Trump to be
personally
liable in civil cases for this. I actually want that to happen.
I realize that's probably never happening. I realize that's probably
a part of his immunity as a as the executive, the head executive
of the country. But holy, he should be civily liable for these
things. Okay? these people coming in, uh, these agents coming
in and like pulling people out of cars and any of the damages,
anything people are getting sued for, he should be personally
liable for it. It' be fantastic.
>> Donald Trump, we don't need your troops here and we're
not going to play a role in your authoritarian games. >> We
got the sentiment from the ground from these protesters. >> ICE
is not welcome here. The National Guard is not >> I know.
I know, Marma. Dude, I don't Dude, I want
I don't know. There's like no way to hold people accountable
for their actions right right now. And that's the problem. There's
nobody's being held held accountable in any way. I want accountability.
Okay, that's what I >> Welcome here. Crime is under control.
>> Yes. No. No. No. I I was almost positive he was immune.
But I'm telling you that I just I there needs to be accountability
for people.
If it's not him, Christy, no. Uh basically everybody >> occupation
doesn't make our city safer. Resources and investment in community
makes our city safer. My family left Eastern Europe because of
the pilgrims. So I think community and collectivism would have
helped at that time. So I think it's my job to protect other
immigrants here. >> We need more social workers, not the
military. Yeah, we tried that. We tried your little woke social
experiment under Joe Biden after the George Floyd riots. And
what happened? Chicago turned into a war zone. Carjackings, shootings,
gang murders, all of it skyro
was that just during CO or
I I'm pretty sure Joe Biden didn't control
police decisions in Chicago, right? Isn't that Wait, why why
are we saying under Trump under B? Why would either of them have
like a say in how Chicago manages their police interactions?
That's like not that's not the point >> the situation.
>> This was never a liberal. This is a Russian bot account
with an AI voiceover. I assume it's like a very old account or
something. Hold on. You think if we go oldest, he'll have like
old videos here?
Camala humiliated by Latino restaurant owner in Florida. So he's
never been a liberal, it doesn't look like, dude, he started
off getting massive views on his videos. What the Oh, he definitely
deleted all of his old videos, right? That's that's more what
we'd expect here is like all of his videos from before 5 years
ago would have been deleted. Yeah. Yeah, I think so. I think
so. Hold on. >> Has become so bad, so untenable in Chicago.
Cash Patel actually really puts that into perspective. the juggernaut
that is demolishing the weaponization of law enforcement, bringing
it to places like Chicago. When I was there today with Todd,
we learned that the Chicago city streets have 110,000
gang members. That's right. You heard me right. They had 1,200
shootings this year alone, 360 homicides. When politicians choose
to side with those metrics and not their citizenry, thank God
we have President Trump and this Department of Justice and this
FBI going in there and crushing violent crime. And President
Trump sent us into these cities quietly to set the stage to set
up for the National Guard to see the success that we saw in Washington
DC in Memphis. The FBI has been leading the charge in >> he
respects Cash Patel. It appears so >> every single one
of these streets because we know how to gather ground level intelligence
and we know how to put handcuffs on the bad guys and we know
that we have the backing of this administration and most importantly
the agents at the FBI know that they have the backing of the
American people and their government. an estimated 5% of
>> It's so cool that Cash Mattel and the FBI went and did
all of this ground work so that these people could tackle this
like fat 50-year-old producer from WGN to the ground and arrest
her after she threw a water bottle at a car. Okay, that's awesome.
Thank you, Cash, for your ground level intelligence. They've
clearly been putting it to great use.
>> Chicago's population are active or affiliated gang members.
That's over a hundred,000 people tied to organ >> backing
of the American people.
>> It's so funny that he said this. He said this right
after you were like incredulous about it. >> An estimated
5% of Chicago's population are active or affiliated gang members.
That's over.
Is that possible?
I feel like that's not like it depends on what you mean by affiliated.
It's like do you have a family member? May maybe I that that
still seems really >> for a 100,000 people tied to organized
crime, drug trafficking, cartel operations, and these idiots
are outraged by Donald Trump wanting to do something about it.
Insanity. It's complete insanity. Dis Can we just like
I I don't understand.
How do people keep getting elected in Chicago who won't deal
with the problem in any way? how it seems like there must be
some disagreement or some argument over what the problems are
and how to deal with them, right? Because how do people keep
getting elected
with like apparently they're just like, "Yeah, we're going to
let criminals do is because of the 5% of the population." Hard
to say. I don't remember that. Uh is there something about Trump
did was Trump's dad from Chicago? Hold on. Does Trump have I
think Trump had um like Roy Cohen was like a mob lawyer. I remember
that. Uh what is it? Fred Trump. Cherry thinks that he was a
like mobster who basically did uh maybe his father or grandfather
like a mobster that did um that was like an informant for the
FBI or something.
I don't know if I've ever seen anything like that. Does he have
a relative like that? I Yeah, I'm not sure. I don't think he
was a New Yorker. He was born in the Bronx,
but I wonder if it maybe it was a grandparent or something.
I don't know.
Why don't
We'd have to figure it out. mobster.
I don't know about that. I know Roy Cohen was like a mob lawyer,
right? And Fred Fred Trump worked with him. So, I don't know.
There might be some connection through that >> victim blaming,
but most importantly, moral inversion. They'd rather invent hoaxes
about ICE agents pointing guns at innocent people, innocent women.
They'd rather defend the trespassing rioters. They'd rather clutch
their pearls about Trump demanding accountability, going after
Democrat leaders who are literally defending and sheltering criminals.
And of course, they'd rather call enforcement of the law orange
man bad authoritarianism.
These people enable lawlessness,
bro.
He is actually just doing the Do you think Do you think that
like eventually this uh this comes down and it is just Knucks
on another account? Yeah, I just found this video. Dude, there's
so much money for these exact opinions.
It's crazy. >> Every turn. And I believe at this point
it's not just political interest. It's not just hypocrisy. It's
malice. How else can you describe it? Oh, we're the bleeding
heart liberals. No, you people are causing untold damage. And
it's kind of hard to maintain this aura of moral superiority
when all you do is lie. And you lie in the most malicious manner.
You lie in ways that protect criminals. You people are out of
your damn minds. And again, I just hope people can see it because
it's so damn clear. Anyways, that's what I got for you guys.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you on the next one. >> So
damn clear.
Did you see Knuck's call for people ex for executing people responsible
for the COVID vaccine? Queen covered it. I did not see that.
Um I know Nu is [__] Honestly, I kind of felt like
Nu was maybe a little too stupid to engage. Like it's kind of
he's like too dumb to engage with. Hold on. Is NXOR doing well
again? Is this channel doing like good again? Dude, this this
other guy is like a bigger problem right now in my opinion.
>> Yeah, Knox
is like This is still a big channel. This is still like a big
guy. This other guy is like worse. This other guy gets like way
more views, doesn't he? This guy gets like way more views in
the same vertical, I think. Oh, no. Yeah. No, he does. He He
puts out so many videos a day. Look at how many videos a day
he puts out that get like massive views.
It's [__] crazy.
No, no does not get more views than this guy. This guy's putting
out multiple views a videos a day that are doing hundreds of
thousands of views,
>> How much in one day? One, two, three, four, four in
the past 24 hours at
And then going back from that, 98,
291, 202,
uh, 135. Does it go two days ago? 135, 127, 244, 113, 338, 240,
200, 465.
This guy's getting crazy views, bro.
This guy's getting insane views right
Yeah. I saw this guy on Twitter and I like looked at this and
I'm like liberal hive mind. What the?
Yeah,
dude. There's just so much money
there's so much money in this in just doing like the Midas touch
slop for people, right?
Like this is just Midas touch. It's all of the Midas touch people
but for
like 30, let's say 21 to 45 year old Republicans.
Somewhere in that range. Yeah.
I don't know. We should maybe check out another video from this
guy. See what See what the content's like.
Got some Hassan videos. Gotcha. You
He had a Destiny video. That's pretty funny.
Uh,
there's no coming back from this.
Hold on. There's no coming back from this.
Let's see. >> Hey guys, welcome to the Liberal Hive Mind,
a channel solely focused on exposing the abundant hypocrisy.
>> Meme of the day. Why is the government shut down? We
need to fund illegals. See, seenor.
This is the This is the bar. This is the bar right here. This
is like This is highle content right here. We got a meme of the
day >> on the left. Absolute world of delusion. That is
the only way to describe what is going on in the modern left
right now. They're living in a different world than we are. You
know, for the last couple of days, we've been covering it. I'm
sure you guys have been exposed to it. We've seen news outlets,
Democrat politicians, Democrat social media heavy hitters all
spreading these false insinuations and false narratives of a
supposed mega arson attack. I feel like it would be fun. Man,
I got to get Listen, we're going for that uh that program or
whatever. Okay, we're going for that program, the um the like
YouTube channel deletion thing. And when we get that, I feel
like I almost want to try to start one of these like right-wing
slop channels and just see if I can make it take off. I think
I can. I think I could. And it would just be really funny to
go do that. Go like put some work into one of these channels
and get it to take off and then be like, "Haha, I was only pretending
to be this actual this whole channel was a >> on a liberal
judge's home and they >> I just think it would be funny
and I don't think it's difficult. I think the the formula is
incredibly clear, right?
I don't know. It' only be a matter of if you're too late. >> This
premise before any evidence had been officially released, before
the investigators even said a single word. And just like I said
in the previous video covering this, this whole thing was going
to backfire on them spectacularly.
And now here we are, what is it, 48 hours later, maybe 72, and
now based on the official statement from authorities, no evidence
whatsoever is pointing to arson. In other words, all these Democrats
lied for the purpose of slandering the other side once again.
And Nicole Wallace at MSNBC, boy, did she take it to a whole
other level doing an entire segment lecturing us about right-wing
incitement to violence against judges and all of it based on
a lie. And really, how despicable to equate criticism of a judge?
Uh Todd Bronson is is basically giving me a theory that
essentially,
okay, just think about this. What do you think about the idea
that somebody just looks at analytics, okay, and they go, "Oh,
this is like a vertical where it's really easy to just like hit
the algorithm like like with gas and just go like super hard
in some direction and you just make a channel based out of like,
oh, I think I could, you know, I know stuff about this. I'm passionate
about it." we just like hit this this exact vertical political
right leaning and I'm going to make like this kind of content
and
you look for a couple features of videos that do well thumbnails
uh certain aesthetic and you just go in that direction with like
no actual moral grounding or anything just you you're like oh
this would be cool this would work monetarily
you think you think this happens pretty often I kind of wonder
if this could be like a thing I don't think that's this guy but
I do think that that's got to happen like pretty often, right?
This is just a product. Why does there need to be passion? Yeah,
that's true.
>> Acting outside of her legal bounds, making clear, despicable
partisan decisions to equate that to incitement to violence,
and then use this phony story to scare people about MAGA terrorism
and fight back against the clear problem they have on their side.
Holy frigin moly, what lowlevel will these lefttoids not stoop
to? Let me show you guys what's going on and let's talk about
it. We got some stuff to get into. So, let's roll the tape. All
right, folks. So, this right here, this is what I mean when I
say you do not hate the lamestream leftist media enough. These
people are not journalists. They are political operatives working
on behalf of the Democrat establishment and they're masquerading
as reporters. They exist to create stories that serve one purpose.
Carry water, defend the Democrats, and attack anybody in association
with President Trump, his movement, or the Am I Am I crazy or
is like the background Do you think the background here is something
he uses a lot or do you think it's the Arena Zerutka murder that
he uses this background like a lot more? I wonder if he just
uses it all the time and he used it even before that. Now I have
to know. Okay, now I got to know. Was he using it like two years
ago? Maybe he was using two years on the website. >> Oh,
he used it like two years ago. Okay. Okay. I was hoping, man.
I was hoping.
Oh [__] Barry Weiss video. Crazy
right at large. >> What we're learning about the fire that
destroyed the home of a South Carolina circuit court judge who
faced criticism from Trump officials after a ruling she made
against the Trump administration.
It comes amid a surge in hostility and threats against judges
as well as criticism directly from the Trump administration,
including for Judge Goodstein after she temporarily blocked the
Justice Department from accessing the files of millions of registered
voters in South Carolina. You know, this is the kind again, we've
talked today already about crossing Rubicons, right?
>> Dude, they're just like, "Hey, the DHS just wants all
the data. Just give it to us, okay?" And somebody's like, "No."
And they're like, "Uh, why do you have to hide? Nothing to hide,
nothing to fear." Is like the mo motto of this DHS. Okay. Nothing
to hide, nothing to fear. >> North Carolina, >> you
know, this is the kind, again, we've talked today already about
crossing Rubicons, right? And when you're starting to attack
judges because of the their rulings, we're in a very very dangerous
position in this country. And it is it makes judges fearful.
It makes prosecutors fearful as we know. It makes others in positions
where they could be crit criticized by Donald Trump fearful.
And he needs to know the power of his voice and how people respond
to that. We've been saying this for years, Nicole, but like if
this is what this turns out to be, some sort of politically motivated
act of domestic terrorism, the importance and significance of
the things that Donald Trump says about a person will be demonstrated
in this instance. >> Absolutely disgusting and it's doubly
dishonest. She's lying about the arson attack or at least heavily
insinuating that it was a MAGA attack and then also lying about
what Steven Miller and other Republicans have been doing and
saying again criticizing a judge for making blatantly partisan
activist decisions is not incitement to violence. It's freedom
blatantly activist partisan decisions. >> speech? Freedom
to criticize. It's called an opinion. And it's funny because
once again they're doing the same thing. Remember
>> this guy have like no idea what a civil liberty is.
>> Bad news. This guy is a Tony fan. There's no way this
guy likes Tony Hinchcliff. There's no way. There's no way. It's
impossible. >> I apologize to absolutely nobody. I love
it. This is the only acceptable response cuz the simple fact
is here that Tony Hinchcliffe did nothing wrong. The only people
who I see are at fault here are those who lied and misrepresented
the context. We all heard the joke. Tony Hinchcliffe called the
island of Puerto Rico a floating island of garbage. And the left
ran with that claiming Donald Trump and Tony Hinchcliffe think
Puerto Rican people are garbage. But that was a lie. Context
matters. As we know, comedy often pushes boundaries to highlight
uncomfortable truths. And so on the surface the joke may seem
offensive, but when you understand the context, it's more of
a dig at the Puerto Rican government, a satirical critique of
systemic mismanagement that has plagued the island of Puerto
Rico than anything else. He wasn't talking about
Oh, wow. Oh, so cool. So, just Okay. What is that? How does that
help?
I
Yeah, listen. I got some interesting stuff over here. Okay.
28 view stream
7 hours ago. The particular Baptist Judaism reputed repudiated.
Sorry. Judaism repudiated. Why is this
28 views. Dude, nobody's seen this. Nobody knows what this channel
is. Why is it recommended to me?
That Pisco. Yeah, this Pisco video does follow me everywhere.
I don't know why. It's like, is it because I'm
I don't know why this video This is like pinned to everything
I look at. Why [__] happening with that? This is
peak desperation. Hold on. This is peak desperation. It's Chank
and Hassan in the thumbnail and then it's an it's an anime girl
talking. >> Desperate to cancel me. Of course, cancelling
me as always. It's another >> So Hassan's uncle.
Dude, there's so much cloaked in Asmin
It's crazy.
I just said this like two minutes ago. That's like why I found
this guy. This guy was Asmin Gold Gunkguarding on Twitter and
I was like, "Oh, this guy looks I clicked on his channel."
Dude, there's so much money in Asmin >> who's a co-founder
of the Young Turks in which Hassan used to work on to my understanding.
Well, >> okay, I don't care cuz we already watched the
video of Aszmold versus Chang. I want to see Asminold's reaction
to the woman or actually, hold on, we can go in a different direction
here. Hold on a second. What do we got? We got 19 minutes left
on the stream. We've got
I think it's six subs. Six subs for another two hours. I've got
one last segment I want to do for sure and then we'll we'll see
if we're going to do more. But I do want to do one last segment
which is uh I want to watch this Glen Beck thing. Okay. Cuz I
don't know if you saw this Glen Beck this Glen Beck um short
going around. >> We have Glenn Beck versus like um some
I assume Groper Heckler. Okay. And it looks like he totally fumbles
it, but I can't tell if it's just clipped up in a certain way.